thank you
good morning right uh
uh representative Emrick is not going to
be here today so I'll be running the
show I guess and uh if you would uh
commissioner uh
welcome to uh division two
um
uh good morning Vice chair uh Petrie and
committee members I'd like to thank you
for the opportunity to present the
budget for New Hampshire Fish and Game
department this morning
um I'm sure some of you looked at our
budget I would like to say the probably
the brightest point in our budget uh is
our increased budget transfer payment to
the trails Bureau
you'll notice that we have budgeted uh
an increase of two million dollars per
year uh to transfer money to the trails
Bureau
our budget request is also up due to the
increase in personnel and benefit costs
also the costs of doit the transfer
costs that we pay to that department has
been increasing with each budget cycle
cost of equipment this year fuel
um over the last biennium we've had to
increase our spending uh on maintenance
or repair items at the Hatchery our
hatcheries have suffered many years of
not having enough money spent on them on
maintenance on replacement parts and
we've spent a lot of money this year
one of the main major issues facing
facing fishing game is outdated computer
databases and still relying too much on
paper manual systems and this path
I'm sorry I apologize
um I don't know your name Scott Mason
okay thank you and are you referring to
a page here or are you reading um just
reading a narrative okay can you sort of
go back to some of the highlights
because I was looking to see where you
were not realizing that you were okay
thank you
um
this budget we've increased
um our expenditure on our transfer of
funds to the trails Bureau by two
million dollars
um we've saw an increase in oh HIV
registrations during covet and we
believe that that will remain uh
probably even more steady than the
increase we saw in license sales
our budget request is up
due to an increase in uh Personnel costs
benefit costs also the doit bill
constantly goes up from budget cycle to
budget cycle
cost of equipment replacement fuel
electricity are all on the rise
in the last biennium we spent a very
large amount of money on fixing Wells
and furnaces at our hatcheries
we are in the process of a study
committee right now looking at our
Hatchery system
so that we can come into compliance with
new EPA permits that one has been issued
and one soon will be
one of the other major issues facing
fish and game is as our outdated
computer databases and we still rely too
much on on the use of paper or manual
systems
uh in the last um biennium one of our
um one of our young
um computer savvy CEOs was able to come
up and launch an online turkey
registration program so we've started
you know that started first our new
Inland Fisheries Chief updated our
Hatchery reporting system in the old
days
um when our folks were out stocking
Brooks or ponds they would write a
ticket and throw it up on the dashboard
of the truck and eventually sometime
they'd get some time they'd clean the
truck up and get all those tickets and
batch them up and send them off and they
would be keyed in by another staff
member well now we've updated we have
iPads in the truck when they stock the
fish they're stocked at a known
GPS Waypoint that is in real time our
Hatchery staff our biologists and our
CEOs know what's going on you know where
we've where we've stocked what we've
stocked how many fish we've stocked
there is a time delay still allow the
fish to acclimate to where they are we
don't give a waypoint but we do give a
general area where we've stocked and
that goes on to our web page
the first 60 days of this being active
we had over three million hits on our
web page people looking up to see where
um so these are just examples of some of
the stuff that we're trying to do to
move the department forward and take
advantage of some of the
um efficiencies the computers and and
and a more technical approach to
managing some of the stuff that we do
would afford US
uh and the next biennium we will be
bringing forth an online deer
registration program updating our
licensing software to prevent convicted
poachers from being able to buy a
license while on suspension online ohrv
renewal registrations
and we are currently working with with
doit to upgrade
um many of our databases we were we
received a gopher Grant and
um we're working through that now
our dit payment in this budget includes
money to pay for a part-time I.T lead
most state agencies already have an I.T
lead this person will help advise staff
and myself better to integrate
Technologies into our system they will
also manage help us manage these upgrade
projects that we're currently working on
as some of you may be aware we have
transformed our aot review program
recently
our current program and Staffing levels
have been re have reduced the processing
time dramatically
this has been funded through a gopher
Grant and was not included in the budget
the Gopher Grant will run out of money
December of 24.
we need to amend the budget
to include 139 thousand dollars to pay
for six months of spending for these
four staff members and general and and
we also need General funding to pay for
this program
the program is crucial for our mission
to protect threatened and endangered
species in New Hampshire
as well as providing timing timely
review so as not to create an undue
burden to development projects in New
Hampshire our non-game program is funded
with donations it would not be it would
be unable to afford this level of
Staffing
and it's not right to ask the New
Hampshire Sportsmen to pay through their
licensing fees for a service that we
um I'd like to take a minute the
governor has approved funding
for our four unfunded conservation
officer positions and I'd like to
introduce Colonel Jordan to speak to
this request uh commissioner could you
uh you had a question uh representative
sure
um
how much What's the total General funds
well you just mentioned that you require
right we're asking another 139 000 there
um
oops
uh in the governor's budget
uh general fund
in uh 24 is 996
665 uh and 90 I'm sorry in 25 it would
be 1.1 million four hundred ninety eight
thousand nine hundred and thirty three
and then today we're asking we're going
to be we just asked for 139 000 more for
the aot program the colonel will be
asking for some more for the for two of
thank you
Representative Keith thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question could
you just
as you um we're discussing all your
um asks could you just
um let us know about the revnos
um covid over the years was very good to
you actually in a way because people had
to be outdoors
um and I know that your revenues were
high could you just help me with that
please yeah we saw an increase in
license sales during the years of covid
um those have started to taper off so
we're not anticipating that to stay with
us at That level
um we are gonna uh we are trying to work
um towards the goal of trying to
convince people to stay buying license
and stay doing outdoor work
to be honest with you one of the biggest
impacts or factors of that in my mind
was actually kids not being in school
because it wasn't just I wasn't just
keeping the adults busy it was keeping
the kids busy and now we're back in
school and sports are back going and all
the activities that kids do and it's
just it you know and I don't think
anybody in the room is not aware of it
it's hard for families to find time to
do to do extra things or do other things
and I think that's what will impact that
our license I'm sorry our
um registration fees on ohrvs uh went
dramatically up
um obviously uh most of that money we
ship over to Trails Bureau we don't keep
it here some of it goes to pay our in
our business office on a registration
some of it goes to pay for law
enforcement activities uh those figures
are up um and they will probably stay up
and if you think through it you know
these machines are you know anywhere
from 10 to 30 40 000 uh if you bought
one during covid chances are it's not
you know if you're not registering it
and you're not using it chances are
you're not going to sit on that type of
investment for very long before you
decide to sell it and hopefully the next
person will register it so we are
thinking that those registration levels
will somewhat stay as high as what we're
seeing currently
representative Heath
um
in terms of online registrations
um that would appear it seems like
um people are anxious to have that
available to them what's your timeline
our timeline
um what we uh offer to the legislature
is have it up and running by September
25 on renewals and then once we get that
done we would start working on uh um
original registrations my staff tells me
uh that in order the doing the original
you know an original registration
there's a lot more places where
um citizens can make mistakes and that
it becomes a lot more complicated a lot
more service involved in those in those
you think we might lose some people to
Vermont and other states by not having
an online product available sooner I
doubt very much you'll lose people of
Vermont
um their trail system is not as well
developed as ours
um also and I'm Colonel Jordan will
probably have a better idea than I would
but I believe that they have an extra
fee for Trails over there that we don't
have so it's I think it's a little bit
more expensive to ride over in Vermont
our true competitor is Maine and then it
becomes an issue of how far you're
willing to drive
especially not so much with ATVs but
when you get into snow machines
obviously that is heavily impacted by
weather we're coming off a year now
where we really didn't get we you know
we had a snowstorm earlier
um the snow
um kind of disappeared it was still in
the higher elevation still at the very
Northern tips of the tip of the state
but um there really wasn't much snow for
when I my my wife and I live in North
Stratford so I'm north of Groveton south
of Colebrook and we had four inches of
snow in the cornfield most of the winter
so there really wasn't a lot of snow
even up north there is now I talked to
my wife this morning and she's out on
the skid steer plowing snow all morning
um
it uh so we do have you know we have
some snow now and they'll be they'll be
riding but just like down here you know
you've had one or two weekends we
probably had four or five up there that
Colonel would you join us yes sir
thank you very much
my name is Kevin Jordan I'm the chief of
law enforcement at New Hampshire Fish
and Game and I've been there for way too
long about 30 years now
um so the reason I came before you today
is we currently have 38 fuel wardens
working in the state men and women that
are working in the field I have four
administrative staff for a total number
of 42 officers covering everything from
Pittsburgh to mass and from the Vermont
border to Maine
um we've had four open unfunded
positions for for about 10 years now
and for the last 10 years I've been
working as hard as I possibly could to
fill those positions uh because we are
short-handed just to give you an idea
State Police has almost 300 troopers on
the road city of Concord has 50 police
officers covering the city I'm trying to
cover the entire state with 38.
and so in 1970 we had 50 game wardens uh
out in the field and today we're
handling triple the calls for service uh
and search and rescue calls over what
they did back in the 70s so I kept
making this plea to the governor and to
anyone who would listen and he did
listen this year he was gracious enough
I I came up with a we came up with a
plan to fund two of those positions out
of our current budget so my plan is to
fund two of these open positions out of
the ohrv account
and I justify that based on the hours
that these officers are spending on oh
hrvs and forcing the the new uh boom of
ohrvs in the North country and so that
money has generated that the calls for
service have generated the reason and
the funding I have available so I plan
to fund two of those out of that the
governor
approved that and then he also allowed
me to to hire the second pair for a
total of four uh and I advised him and
we advised him that we didn't have the
funding in the fish and game fund for
that so I would need that funded out of
General funds and I Justified that by
explaining to him I did a lot of work on
how we spend our time and basically uh
one thing people don't realize a lot of
the calls for service nuisance Wildlife
search and rescue calls bear nuisance
calls are being calls for service are
being demanded of our officers by folks
that haven't bought hunting their
fishing licenses so they haven't
contributed really other than to this to
the finances of the system other unless
they bought a hunting license and so
these officers are spending eight to ten
percent of their time responding to
these calls so
um asking for that to come out a general
fund to me two officers positions made
sense so that's the the bid that I put
in it didn't get written into the budget
was my understanding this year so I'm
here today asking for that funding for
those two positions to come out of
General funds and the total for that
would be and I'll get you I apologize
that I didn't bring anything in writing
today I will do that I was kind of short
notice that I was going to be here today
to present this but I will reduce this
all to writing and get it back to the
committee
um this is going to be a cost of about a
hundred and seventy one thousand dollars
uh each year in the biennium to fund
those two positions I I will tell you I
desperately need those and and a couple
of other things I would ask you to
consider so what happens to us is when
you have those 38 field offs on any
given day you have days off vacations so
it's rare that you have that many staff
on board so on an average day we're
working with 15 to 18 officers in the
field if I get a search and rescue call
that requires a carryout I need every
one of those officers to respond it
requires 20 people to carry someone at a
couple of miles down down a trail physic
it's very physically demanding and and
so what ends up happening and has
happened many times for us uh an officer
gets to the base of that trail we're
called to a second call and he turns
around and goes back up or or goes on
another call what I've noticed that this
is doing is it it is increased my injury
to my officers because they're tired and
they're getting hurt more which is
driving up our workman's comp cost but
more importantly as I'm calling in
officers more and more now on days off
I'm requiring them through our labor
contract requires them to be on call 24
hours a day so I am reaching out to
officers on days off and making them or
requesting that they come back so that
we can conduct these missions that's
coming at a premium cost as payroll goes
up I'm paying some of those guys seventy
dollars an hour where I would be paying
them forty dollars an hour if they were
on a regular workday that's a huge
expense to our overtime and I noticed
that my overtime is climbing higher and
higher each year and so I see these four
positions as not curing that but
certainly helping it to balance off some
of that cost so so those are the things
that I would ask you to consider
representative Heath thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question
um today on the television I heard that
somebody was in tuckerman's were being
caught in of lunch now um are there
I know Tech member Serene from my
younger days when you I used to go up
there all the time yeah
we never could go up there like in a
month of March because of the danger
um but it seems like people are
um going into parts of New Hampshire now
more frequently than ever before and
your folks are getting called out in the
worst of circumstances to help them
luckily some have the cards so you can
locate them right but some of them don't
have that that's correct um
are there any restrictions on as to
where people can go or do you need some
kind of safety measures in place so
people aren't killing themselves we've
tried and you're you are absolutely
correct they're getting more and more
dangerous uh more and more technical
those rescue missions are now we're
using ropes more and climbers more we
had to create a specialized team that we
train and equip at levels beyond the
regular game warden because of that but
I have never had any success
in my multiple years of discussions with
white Mountain National Forest and AMC
quite frankly to to put in any of those
restrictions so on a day as you saw in
the news where where the the possibility
of avalanche is high and will remain
high based on the snow the way that
we've got any snow it is perfect
Avalanche weather to not uh to to
restrict skiers there makes sense no
one's doing that and I've had no success
in getting that uh and so you watch this
kid sliding down the slope into the
Rocks literally I don't very fortunate
you survived that uh and I and I worry
that uh like in the weather we had two
weeks ago where it was 60 below zero on
top of Mount Washington it was in the
80s 80s 80 below and that challenges
people to go up there and try to survive
that so again that cost the state of New
Hampshire a lot of money and I don't
know how to stop that I'd be all on
board with that if we could restrict
that but it's a it's a slippery slope I
think we'll tell you
I do whatever chance I get
representative Weiler was was the author
uh of and extremely helpful in getting
that hike safe card passed we were in
financial Straits without that that this
past year produced 200 000 which was
half of the cost of my rescues for the
year for the State of New Hampshire that
was a big bonus to the department I
fight to keep it because everybody tries
to change it it's a great program I
don't want it messed with and we're
doing very well with it so
yes that was a plan that came from this
house that has worked very well so
senator
no that's right that's right but it's a
help it's it's at least they're at least
paying for some of that service which is
important and it gives us an opportunity
to sell the safety points too that's
what we've used it for
so
uh
Mike
I'm trying to run away from this thing
I know that feeling
um
so that you're requesting for
full-time employees two are gonna are
you gonna two are going to be able to
come from ohrv that's correct and two
have to come from general fund that's
correct okay thank you thank you sir
representative Murray
thank you
um two questions
um
there have been a number of
unfortunate is not a strong enough word
um deaths yes um people up there and
um we all know
what was so unfortunate about it
um it used to be that
if you were totally ill prepared if you
were not following that then
the victim or the victim's family was
pursued for funding for a rescue
um is that still the case and my second
question is can you just give a brief
overview of how your officers are
trained yes so to answer the question on
billing we still the legislature has
allowed us to that was one of the
solutions when we made multiple runs
back to fund search and rescue so they
allow us to Bill try and recover the
cost from Reckless hiking I've never
done it with a fatality I've never gone
to a family after a loss of a child or
or a loved one and asked to be paid
um I could probably certainly in the in
little Emily's case I could have she was
she was it was unbelievably preventable
there were three right in a row that's
correct
um and and so I could have in that case
but I've never done that we do bill so
we do 180 excuse me 180 to 185 missions
a year I bill on average 10 to 12 of
those that Meet The Reckless standard
that both the Attorney General's office
and we agree and will then in fact bill
um I came before the house this year
because uh part of that law allowed us
or or required us to suspend driver's
licenses if in fact they didn't pay that
bill I've only used that when I've got
people that refuse to contact us at all
to have any contact with us so I'm over
here this year trying to get that link
that language strengthened because it
was never written correctly
um but uh and so we do do that we end up
setting up payment plans it's uh it's
probably
it probably cost us money quite frankly
it it doesn't save me a lot but you know
what it does it's two things it does
that I owe us dollar press I can't
measure one is I know for a fact it
prevents some of these missions I don't
know how to
follow that to tell you how many but
when people think about getting a bill
it causes them to take a thought because
they call me and they'll ask me what's
the appropriate gear I should bring
what's the and that never used to happen
so it is a good thing and I don't want
to lose it but we don't use it often for
those reasons and I would never bill for
a child or a fatality we just never
would do that our training if we receive
the same training as any police officer
in the state of New Hampshire so we're
training criminal law we're trained in
Fish and Game law I we give them a
little added training when they come out
of the academy to address the issues
they're going to face as a game award so
things like the bio biological end of it
how to deal with a bear complaint how to
load litters how to do search and rescue
search and rescue
and the training that the officers
receive to ride the specialized
equipment remember when when an officer
comes on I'm giving them a boat
sometimes more than one boat depending
on their patrols a small boat a bigger
boat for the bigger bodies we're giving
them an ATV or a dirt bike to respond to
enforce oh HIV laws we're training them
to ride a snow machine so they're
getting all of that training and then
they all receive search and rescue
training I have 16 of them
that get search and rescue training
above and beyond the rest so those are
the guys that we guys and gals that we
send above Tree Line uh in the winter
time I won't send a regular game warden
up today I would send only someone from
that specialized team we equip them with
more expensive more technical equipment
and they are training
um constantly throughout the year along
with my dive team that that is very
similar so those guys receive levels of
training much greater and that is an
ongoing thing they're getting
30 40 hours of training a year just in
that regard alone to be able to do what
they're doing
the other point that I want to make
and I know you I know you're busy and I
appreciate you entertaining this but
when you send officers up to bring down
a kid
that's frozen that they literally
chiseled out of the ice and brought down
that's not a normal thing for anyone to
and you know I was there in that day I
went up there that day because my staff
had been there for four days and it was
a brutal rescue and I did a lot of them
when I was a real game warden in the
field so I know what it takes and you
know I go around and talk to those guys
quietly and I say you know this is this
is a bet no it's okay it's what we do
well it isn't what you do no one does
that and when you repeatedly expose
these same individuals to this there's
there's a price for that there's a price
physically and there's a price
emotionally and when you have short
staff numbers that increases that issue
so that's part of the motivation that I
come back and ask for more people is
because you need to spell these guys out
sometimes from that I had the same crew
that brought Emily down went up four
days later and brought another young man
down in the same condition that's not
normal and there aren't a lot of
agencies that are put in that position
so
I have quite a few questions oh okay
um
I I don't I don't think people realize
how many people it takes for a carryout
they don't and they don't I know that um
I'm from Conway and the Conway Village
fire district used to go in there and
and get people out and it takes eight or
ten people and then and uh
it it can go on for hours right you can
you know I did it for I've had both my
shoulders replaced and and I can tell
you it was it was due to rescues so
you're carrying a strap across your back
and holding a person in a litter 150 to
180 pounds sometimes more in a litter
and you're off trail that unfortunately
the litter is over the trail you're
walking off that trail and it beats you
up yeah and the only way and what
happens is you've gotta you've got to
turn these people you've got to turn
these people over because you're going
to end up dropping the patient so you
got to have people to rotate in and out
so it requires you're right it requires
a lot of people thank goodness for
volunteers because we the professional
volunteers that we use because we
couldn't do it without them with 38
officers I would not be able to do it
can can you just give a ballpark figure
of what it average an average number of
people that it takes to carry somebody
out I know what varies but no so in on a
mile carryout a mile to a two mile
carrier which quite frankly is probably
the average you you're gonna you
wouldn't want to do that with less than
20 people you would want 20 people 20.
yes you would need 20 people thank you
effectively we've done it with less but
you but ideally you would want 20 people
yeah so once you get there you have to
call for additional violence absolutely
you do absolutely you do and that's why
I'm calling guys in on days off yeah and
they're not liking that either right
right that's not fair to them frankly
thank you so
um you mentioned a lot about the price
that your officers are paying for this
you know deeply tragic service they have
to provide
um and you did mention that workman comp
workman's comp is up
for the Department my my question is
is there any sort of um crisis you know
provide Provisions to these team members
you know for their for their emotional
mental well and I'm laughing because we
we would just the last conversation I
had at my office before coming over here
was over that exact issue so we have a
psychologist that is asked to put on a
class for us tomorrow and I've mandated
that the officers go and bring their
spouses with them so
um so we do get that and I did it and
before I got this position uh I was in
critical incident debriefer for the
agency due to a shooting I was in years
ago so I would go around and do that we
don't I haven't backfilled that that's
something that we need to do I think
um
but because these new kids don't share
like the older guys did that's it's a
different personality and I have real
concerns about that moving forward but
yes we do bring that in we recognize
that that in the old days that was not
allowed in law enforcement you sucked
that up and that's just foolish that's
not wise business because you've got a
lot of money invested in these people
and I want to get 20 years out of them
I've got hundreds of thousands of
dollars in them and and not only do I
want them healthy which is really what I
want I sell it because we've invested
this kind of money so you need to pay
for this training so that they we keep
representative
thank you Mr chair I really appreciate
it I have about five different questions
because they accumulated and just as a
heads up after this I will have to
briefly head out there is somebody who I
need to be out there for
so let me start by again thanking you
for taking the questions and uh I just
want to make sure I understand
everything correctly you were talking
earlier about the hives psych safe card
if I recall correctly that's a voluntary
program that is a voluntary people can
choose to use it they get extra benefits
from having it but it's a voluntary
program it is Sir I mean I don't see why
anybody would want to tweak with a
voluntary program that seems to benefit
everyone and I will you know say that we
need to if anything extend it and look
at what changes we can make to it to
make it more useful you were talking
earlier about the um situations where
the conditions are dangerous but you
cannot ban people from going out and
frankly I think enforcing that ban would
be amazingly difficult for you anyway
because you cannot exactly you know
Patrol those areas I'm I just want to
make sure that we do inform people of
the dangerous conditions
and then you know they make their own
choices that involve risk but we do have
a system to notify them that there is an
avalanche risk or the weather is too
cold up and you shouldn't go up how do
we do that so we have a number of ways
we do that when Governor sununu first
took over we had three at a fishing
there we had three people go through the
ice I don't know if anyone remembers
that last a few years ago uh it was it
was a tragedy unfolding and he wanted to
shut the lake down I'll never forget
that phone call he said we got to shut
down Lake Winnipesaukee I said Governor
I don't know how I could do that he said
I'll deploy the guard and we'll do that
I said you you cannot manage that what
we need to do and he helped me he was a
great help I said what we need to do is
we need to do a public service campaign
and tell people this is dangerous and
this is how you avoid that danger so I
do that a lot on Channel Nine I do it
with a whole host of different officers
and in fact almost to the point where
it's at nauseam I think but but I think
that's the best way to do it and channel
9 has been very good to us all our press
releases have a paragraph at the bottom
talking about that the dangers and how
to the 10 10 essential hiking items that
you should have in your pack so we do a
huge Public Service campaign through the
press for that exact thing now at the at
the Mount Washington they post where
hikers arrive at tuckerman's there's a
big sign up there that's updated daily
due to dangers the problem is people
walk right by it
but but the sign is there we do a lot to
warn people so that should be no
surprise we can only do so much I mean
at the end of the day we'll never be
able to put them in a cocoon and keep
them safe there is risk in involved in
any outdoor activity we should continue
to educate and inform people and hoping
that they will learn from other other
people's mistakes sure you were also
talking earlier about the billing for
Rescue and your you know attempts to
collect and how you are trying to be
considerate of you know the
circumstances
I'm a numbers person do you have a
collection percentage on those attempts
to build how much do we end up
recovering you were saying that it may
not even make sense financially but it's
more of a deterrent last year we covered
62 percent of the ones I build so a
couple over half and the reason I know
that as I just presented these figures
to the outdoor Council
um we sold 211
000 worth of hikesafe cards we build 12
hikers total of that 12 and I I
apologize I didn't bring those numbers
with me but I calculated how much we
build and how much we collected but it
was a 62 just looking for a ballpark and
you really am trying to get the feeling
by the way 62 percent is a really high
rate of recovery I mean it's pretty good
those are a lot of the times they're not
people who have the resources and what
are you gonna do you cannot you know get
blood out of us and we just so you know
we we will negotiate that because
depending on so they all press always
asking what's an average rescue that's
very difficult to answer because they
can run as as little as 1000 dollars and
they can run as high as a hundred
thousand depending on what you're using
for resources and some of these
helicopter rescues if I was built for
the helicopter they'd be over over
they'd take my whole budget for one
rescue
um but so we negotiate that you can't
bill someone forty thousand dollars and
expect them to be able to pay that so
I've called them and negotiated that
down
um and and I suppose you have to do that
carefully it just it just never made
sense to me to expect someone to be able
to pay a thirty five thousand dollar
bill when they're renting an apartment
and on the key frankly most people who
could pay that probably know better than
to cause a rescue right so we reduce it
and we'll agree on a price and then set
them up with a time payment I think
you're managing it in a very very
appropriate way and I appreciate the
details
um one is slightly less comfortable
question if I may there was a bill
earlier that didn't make it through on
uh you know the warrantless search power
of the fission game people I just want
to ask Point Blank
whether you guys have the policies in
place to make sure that that power is
used strictly for fish and game purposes
and not for any other lawyer we
absolutely do and one thing that it the
testimony in that was very misleading
had you if you had gone to the committee
uh the the when I wrote that statute
myself I wrote the last paragraph when
we got motor vehicle Powers when we got
motor vehicle Powers because we were
stumbling on to driving people that were
driving that were impaired and we didn't
have the if I pulled someone over who
was impaired when I was out working
night Hunters at night that guaranteed
that individual would be found not
guilty in a courtroom because I didn't
have the authority to do that so I
brought that before the legislature and
I said that makes no sense we need to
have we're trained the same levels State
Police can enforce all of our laws we're
allowed to enforce all of theirs with
the exception motor vehicle I would ask
that we do motor vehicle and the concern
came up about our abilities to check
folks in the field a little added it's
not really extra power but we are
allowed by law so to look to see if you
have a number of fish if you've been
able you know if we have we have to have
articulable suspicion you can't just
guess at that you have to have a reason
you have to see it happening or suspect
that it's happening and you have to be
able to articulate that when you go to
court so that was a concern in Motor
Vehicles so I wrote right in that statue
had he read the entire statute I wrote
right in there fish and game officers
will have will be able to stop motor
vehicle with no additional Authority
than any other licensed or certified
police officer which means I can do
nothing more on the highway than a
trooper can which is the way it should
be which I appreciate a clarification
please note this is my first term so I
really have a lot to learn and I get
very frustrated watching that live on
the house floor knowing that the
information being provided is absolutely
false the other thing I will tell you is
this
just remember the world that we live in
today the scrutiny that law enforcement
is under some degrees that's a good
thing because it's cleaned us up I think
in some areas outside of the State of
New Hampshire that's required this is
not the time that you would get away
with any of those extra Powers the
Supreme Court would snap those away from
you this particular law has gone before
our New Hampshire Supreme Court three
separate times and been upheld all three
of those times it's 80 years worth of of
judicial review if there was a problem
it would have changed a long time ago I
appreciate it and I'm gonna you know my
last question is uh totally different
one it's the happy one for the end
all those volunteers that help us with
bring something to thank them and to
show them our appreciation any perks
anything we can do for them to again
show them that you know we genuinely
appreciate
oh yes so you the legislature has given
us the ability to cover them Insurance
wise so when those folks come we have to
jump through some hoops they have to be
not just a necessarily a person off the
street but some of these professional uh
volunteers that train with us we sign
them up to become temporary employees if
you will so they're covered for
workman's comp so if one of them gets
injured we can we can pay their medical
expenses doesn't happen often but when
it does happen it's nice to be able to
cover that we also provide them with we
have a group excuse me called The
Outdoor Council
which is a group of board members to
include officers from my agency they get
we solicit donations for the search and
rescue so you'll have like Emily
sotelo's family has donated thousands of
dollars for the work that was done we
give it to the outdoor Council and that
money is used to I forbid any of my
officers or any of our agency to get any
of that because we're being paid so that
all goes to the volunteers when we
purchase radios for them we purchase
clothing for them we train for them we
play softball with them we take them out
whenever we can so we treat them it's a
very good relationship I appreciate that
and again we would be lost without those
folks thank you that's why I'm asking
because as I said you know I'm new to
all of this and it seems that it's only
right that we show them you know how
much we appreciate it and again I'll
have to step or for a few minutes I
apologize thank you
representative buco
thank you Mr chairman
uh Colonel is it colonel Kevin is fine
sir
um as I recall when we approved that
motor vehicle provision yes it will
speak the main reason was because of a
lot of the traffic coming out of Jericho
and going in into town right so what's
happening with the park now because it
seems like uh
I think it's when I see the trailers
going through Conway I I know it's busy
up there they've that we they have we've
all done I think a better job of getting
a handle on that when that exploded
things were a little in disarray we had
roads opened up we still have roads
opened up a lot of the local PDS didn't
want to get involved in it uh we've
changed a lot of that mindset now I
think we're all working in the same
direction
um you know we're doing details in the
summertime up at the park I'm working
some of those in the on the weekends in
the summer because we're short-handed
um so that the park has really done a
good job at corralling those issues so
and you're correct part of the motor
vehicle issue came it came a little
ahead of that but it but it would it
helps us to address them driving down
the roads in addition to the Fish and
Game law we can force so it was a it
just made sense to do that and I don't
know why it wasn't ever done but but
it's it works well and you're not not
out I don't have staff enough to have
them out on 93 running a radar gun and
you won't see them doing that or they're
going to be looking for work because
there's too many other things for them
to do what I said to them and and tell
them routinely is
if someone runs a red light when I'm
going home and puts another person in
danger I will stop that vehicle I'm not
going to stop a guy who goes by me on 93
probably 10 miles over the speed limit
because quite frankly that's not my job
but if it's creating a hazard to people
and it's placing people in danger then I
I want these officers to address that
and they've been doing that there hasn't
been a lot of that Vehicles being
stopped but they use it in those extreme
cases
well thank you for that response I I
think it was more of
or oh hiv's coming off the trails and
going down the sidewalks right yeah
that's that has gotten better not that
we don't have issues still but it is it
is improved it has improved thank you
representative Murray
thank you just a quick question do I
recall correctly that you have a K-9
unit or the canines belong to your
professional volunteers no so well we
have five canine units of our own that
we have funded without any state money
so we have we have I have a very
successful very highly regarded canine
program that I didn't have anything to
do with but I have officers that created
it that is all funded through uh
donations I'm very proud of that
um because it is some of the officers
are some of the best equipped in New
England and we don't pay anything for
that not a state budget money
we also use a group we've used for years
New England K-9 I will use them when we
have a situation where there's no danger
involved so those are civilian people
that have trained their dogs their scent
dogs and they're part of our volunteer
base I use our dogs for the criminal
um element of it although my dogs are
not bite dogs they're search dogs but
these dogs have been you our dogs have
also been used in the last number of
homicides in the state to include the
Concord homicide here they found the
evidence that would end up getting that
guy arrested they found the gun up on 93
in the medium for the young man who
killed his stepmother and children
brother or sister remember in Northfield
so those dogs are being called Down by
State Police because of their abilities
we also use New England K-9 which are
tracking dogs the volunteer base so we
right uh Colonel um
let me get this straight now oh Civil
Air Patrol how much interaction do you
have with them and uh I know I was on
the last year I went up on a training
Mission uh you know a fake mission to uh
and they showed me how it works with
that kernel we use them a lot actually
we use them the limitations that we have
with civil air patrols they're fixed
Wing aircraft so their ability to
um to fly and see what we need
um is is a lot of times too high I still
we still use them as a resource you call
out a mission number as you know and you
go through the you jump through the
Hoops to use them for that I use you
know what I use more of they are they
are the go-to organization for forensic
phone work
they can pinpoint phone calls for me
9-1-1 calls they are the group that has
been able to narrow down locations when
we've had a caller call in and either uh
couldn't couldn't make another call or
his phone went dead uh Civil Air Patrol
has done an outstanding job with pinning
that down for us so we we use them I use
their ground crew sometimes when I can I
don't use them in the winter time
because they don't want to come in the
winter but they'll they'll work in the
summer so we use them I think they would
like us to use them more
that I'm always getting pushed back from
them but frankly when I when I need
someone to fly at Treetop level or lower
my team out on a cable or pick a victim
up there's only one group in the state
of New Hampshire can do that and that's
our Army Air National Guard uh those
Pilots are amazing and we we train with
them we can communicate with them and
it's a helicopter so it gives me more
ability to use them in more scenarios
but we use the fixed wings for these
long-term searches like Emily I know we
use Civil Air Patrol for Emily those
four days that we were on Lafayette so
we use them quite a bit yeah it's very
difficult to see from that altitude let
me tell you yes it's not yes and I don't
want them to ever hear me say that
because they get quite offended by that
but it's just it's just common sense
they're flying an aircraft at as
representative Weiler I know is is has
done at very high distances and and a
lot of these times I need a helicopter
ride a treetop and uh right and the
guard is I use state police helicopters
too we use those as well but the guard
is really what has helped us the most it
has saved lives for us right and one
other question uh Wireless could you go
through the scenario of you know like I
you you mentioned it you touched upon it
as far as if someone if an officer sees
someone say fishing yes it's not
supposed to that's something yep that's
probable cause right that's right
articulable suspicion could you go
through the warrantless
if you let's say you
realize that you probably oh the officer
needs a warrant yep what what could you
go through that scenario sure so I can
give you a couple of different scenarios
that happens so typically what happens
is I will watch a fisherman
and I've seen him catch one or two fish
and he I'm watching him with binoculars
which is what we do every day and he's
putting them in a basket or a cooler or
a bag or in his coat pocket so I know
that he has at least caught two for
instance and he's put them in this
location now I have articulable
suspicion which is different from
probable cause probable cause is a much
higher level probable cause is better
than greater than 51 percent I can prove
that he has committed an offense
articable suspicion is I think he did I
need more evidence to prove that that's
what gets a motor vehicle stop I think
he's speeding because my radar says he
is so I'm gonna pull him over you don't
need a search warrant to do that you're
pulling him over you're asking him for
his driver's license if he's been
drinking you're getting him out you're
getting it you're doing a test that's
all searching that are allowed police
officers are allowed to do but getting
back to my scenario my guys put his fish
in his pocket so now I've decided rather
than sit there I want to go check him so
I go down the bank we have a very
friendly conversation
um how's the fishing today it's it's
good or it's not good did you catch any
fish
now his response to that could mean one
of two things if he says yes then then
that's not going to help my articable
suspicion much other than I know he's
got some and I know he's got them
because I've seen him if he says no
he's helped me a lot because I know he's
caught at least two because I watched
him
so I am within my rights under that law
to now say to him do you mind showing me
those fish now I could go in his coat
without doing that I would fire an
officer if he did that you can't do that
to people there's nothing wrong with
saying I saw you catch a couple of fish
or I'd like to see the fish you caught
today and you know 99 of the time he'll
pull the fish out and show them to you
once in a while they won't and now if
say he doesn't do I have articable
suspicion to go in there I certainly do
I certainly do
that doesn't give you our checkable
suspicion to go into his front pants
pocket okay because there's no trout in
that you saw it go in the code that
better be where you go do you understand
that if you go into the pants pocket you
don't have a reason to do that and so
now if you fi if you want to go into
those pants pockets and because you
think he has uh you get up there and you
can smell the odor of uh well marijuana
is probably not good to use but it's
what I used to because it's legal in
some places now but if you if you saw
what you believe to be
um or a suspected drug activity it
doesn't allow you to go in there and get
that you would have to stop at that
point and hold him make a decision that
you're going to hold him and go apply
for a search warrant and you would have
to apply for that did you do that online
so the testimony of that is very
inaccurate
there in the old days I would go find a
friend of mine a judge and I'd go to his
house I've been to campgrounds I've been
to their camps I go to their homes that
has all stopped you can't do that any
longer now they put judges on call and
you have to do it telephonically over on
the phone and so that would require so I
could call a judge on the phone and give
him my probable cause that I need for a
warrant I have to have a little more
than just a suspicion for that and then
I have to go somewhere where I can send
him that information in an affidavit so
I have to have a computer to do that
this this testimony you can do that with
a phone is nonsense you need to have
something in writing you have to swear
that that is the truth the way you swear
is you become an affient by signing that
so that's not done on the phone we just
did we've got a big case that you're
going to see hit the news here very soon
which will be very alarming and we've
been working on it for months and it
involved us getting search warrants for
telephones and computers and we got I
think we're up to 12 or 14 different
applications for warrants that we
applied for and again the testimony made
it sound like we don't ever do that we
do it regularly just like any other
police officer does
in one scenario that I was involved in
we applied for that warrant at 10
o'clock in the morning we never heard
back from the judge until five that
evening now in this particular case it
wasn't a big deal because they didn't
know we were coming back to get the
phone if I've got a guy standing on a
brook
I can't hold him there for the day I
can't tie up a lobster boat and look at
a fisherman who's trying to make a
living and say you're going to have to
wait till four above until we get the
judge you know I'm gonna get we're going
to get killed doing that that's just not
reasonable that is why in every state in
the country
they allow us the Opera the ability to
go in and look for these things without
the warrant that's the whole reason for
that is it's not conducive it's not as
easy as people think we can do it and
we're required to I cannot go into a
home ever
without a search warrant thank God
I mean I'd be the first one to object to
that I'm a firm believer in our
constitution you cannot go into people's
homes you're not going to open people's
trunks you're going to have search
warrants for that stuff
in spite of what anyone tells you that
isn't done and I have asked repeatedly
when this bill has come before the house
seven times I think now give me one just
one example of an officer or a scenario
where that was done to this day you've
not heard one and you didn't that day
because they don't exist it's never
happened
and and as long as it doesn't that rule
should never change if it happens then
yes we should jump all over that but I
can tell you the courts will do it for
you the courts would accept less
nonsense today than ever in my 33-year
career I might have gotten away with
something my first five years today you
are not going to get away with anything
like that so so it's not as easy as
people think
anybody else
um that's a long answer I'm sorry
wow mine's in a completely different
subject
um do you ever use um drone technology
so we just again through a donation I
had an officer apply a young officer who
created the uh
turkey registration the director was
talking about that same officer is a is
a drone fanatic I did not know this he
came to me with a proposal a very well
crafted one uh he sold me on it we
applied for a grant through the wildlife
Heritage Foundation so because we didn't
have the money in the budget for that
they awarded the Grant and so we are
purchasing a drone to start that so
we'll see how that goes
it'll be very tricky because of FAA
rules and other other limitations and
flying it above four thousand feet above
tree line but it's just going to be
another tool in the toolbox that we hope
to use so
represent oh chairman whyler
thank you Mr chairman I usually get a
solicitation a couple times a year from
non-game and fishing they send me the
wild lines I don't think I've gotten one
yeah
it must be an oversight because I do
know that they've gone out because I'll
make sure to I look down usually see I
look down I haven't seen a check that I
sent to him lately so okay and I you
know I think that's good even though
it's a small piece of the program it's
representative I'm sorry I have one
final question thank you Mr chair with
all the donations
um
how was that captured is there an
accounting process for the donations
that you are given
because it sounds like a lot
of we get a lot of law enforcement I've
I've gotten a million dollar safe boat
just recently we got a airboat that was
two hundred thousand dollars that was
that was through donations I just got a
ten thousand dollar donation from a
former senator who wanted to help out
with search uh searching uh search and
rescue missions so we we go to uh
commission for approval on each one of
these from so we'll name the the donor
and the amount and then anything 2500
and above Kath we go to G and C governor
and Council so that's approved and then
that is added I'm also Kathy is is my
guardian for that and I can tell you you
don't want to cross Kathy so she is very
strict about where that money goes so if
money was provided to us for search and
rescue that's the account you put it in
if money isn't provided for a canine
that's the account line that that you
deposit that in and that does show I our
budget correct
thank you for your time thank you very
much
I still have one more thing good job
shoot
um I would like to take a moment and
invite um Kathy Labonte up
um one of our department requests uh
that the governor did not uh put into
his budget was funding for a senior
accounting technician labor grade 14 in
our business office and I would like
Kathy to address our request uh the
budget director has knows that I'm here
today and has approved me being here to
make this request to the legislature
thank you hi Kathy labani chief of the
business division we submitted our
agency request efficiency budget and
then we had our prioritized needs per
the instructions within those
prioritized needs we had nine unfunded
positions that were within those columns
in one newly created position called a
7D
four of those unfunded positions were
approved by the governor's office and
those are the conservation officers that
the colonel and the director have
alluded to those are represented within
our budget that is before you
I am here because I requested that a
position that used to reside within the
department that was taken from us
I asked for to be re-established and it
was denied by the governor's office back
in 2013 I had an accounting technician
leave a grade 14 when the legislature
created uh The Authority for das to
create the shared services Center for
accounts payable and Human Resources
functions
so my one and only accounts payable
position was taken from fish and game
and put over with the shared services
Center to process accounts payable
however half of the accounts payable
duties that went along with her position
were left at the agency
processing requisitions research
customer service with vendors the only
thing that went with Vivian in position
number 13910 was the data entry
component of accounts payable
as you may be aware if you were here at
the time in 2017 the shared services
Center was disbanded because it was not
the efficient module that we were all
kind of led to believe it was going to
be when it was disbanded agencies were
provided an opportunity to get the
positions back that were grabbed from
them in 2013.
in the meantime during that 40-year
period of time the position that was
taken from fish and game had retired she
very much did not like the shared
services Center she retired early so at
the time her position number her
full-time position number was abolished
by Das so I had no full-time position
number two come back to fish and games
so I didn't have anybody to claim
so because of the um kind of balance in
the fish and game fund and this is a
full-time Fish and Game funded position
within the business office as most of us
are
I decided along then with uh director
Normandale that we would just absorb
those accounts payable duties at the
time
but due to the increase in the workload
as program areas have increased accounts
payables have increased our grants our
volume of Grants have increased the
establishment of the Statewide
purchasing card
I asked for this position to be
re-established within the department the
governor
decided not to fund it so I am here
before you to ask for your consideration
in funding this full-time position that
really is in a new position it's to
re-establish a position that used to
exist within our department
like Roseanne Buco thank you Mr chairman
can I ask you to uh give me the the
um the title of the position again the
title is a senior accounting technician
is that from licenses and fees
unrestricted Fish and Game funds yes sir
um
seven D's could you define those uh I
you mentioned that and I seen in another
presentation I apologize a 70
West that agencies
mitt during the agency process for a new
position
we submit them to the Department of
administrative Services as a newly
established position it has provided a
temporary position number through the
division of personnel
and it comes through to the agencies and
through Das with funding in our
anybody else
um I would be I think a little remiss I
we were having a discussion before uh
the meeting started and um and I
apologize you're Eric
mcmick sorry
um
uh he informed me that I think we're the
first agency to come forward with this
issue with a gopher funding on our aot
program where the go for money is going
to run out you know we it's not in our
regular budget because it was funded
through the Gopher program so the money
Runs Out uh halfway through fiscal 25
and we're asking to maintain that
program which means right now that's you
know we need to put that as us we have
to have the authority to spend money we
have to find the money someplace to
spend so my I just want to remind folks
my request to you folks was to add that
as a spend line item
um and Kathy I'm gonna need some help on
where to put it but and then also to get
some general funds to cover to cover the
item
and I believe what I was told is we're
actually the first agency to come before
um Finance with this request but there
are several others out there that either
will or or have or will be making the
request at some point thank you so so
you're you're about four hundred
thousand dollars extra no it was 139
000. 100 oh yeah plus yeah yeah plus the
100 uh
you know in a way it's that's that that
works out representative Murray thank
you can you say
um what will go away if the money isn't
replaced what are these four individuals
doing that they won't be doing so right
now
um they're part of our environmental
review team so when Des if you need to
get an aot permit from Des or Wetlands
permit from Des and there are endangered
or threatened species on the property
that you wish to develop
um you you receive notification of that
and then you have to file with phishing
game and we come up with a plan to
mitigate possible damages to those
species as part of that when I came on
prior to me coming on there was a
lawsuit that that radically changed the
EES is that basically threw out their
law the new law came in we came in with
new regs and it it it was a very slow
process we were not able to keep the
pace up we have since we written our
regulations and working with the
governor we received this go for funding
to staff this program at its at it at a
level that that we're able to keep up to
Pace part of the issue would go for
um you gotta remember there's a lot of
federal money coming into the state of
New Hampshire right now so we're
probably seeing a higher level of
development more applications right now
than what we may see
you know on the other side of all this
federal spending so it's kind of part of
it is temporary that's the reason why we
don't have a firm plan to put forth
because right now you know we're not
exactly sure I need four people or maybe
I need two people or maybe I need three
people long haul these positions were
all created as temporary positions so
that we have flexibility with that and
we will be continuing to study this as
we go forward
but the big issue was is that you know
we did not put it into our budget for
this last six months and if we stopped
um
it would endanger
not being a lawyer but my my um
my opinion would be that it would
probably endanger t e species on
developmental sites because of the laws
that we have right now on the books we
have X number of days to do the review
if we don't if we like Des we don't do
the review then then it's considered a
yes so there'd be no protection for T
you know it would not be significant
protection for tne species on
development sites
uh threaten and endangered sir
um
have you always done this or before
gopher did it go through Des we no it's
always been a fishing game but prior to
the lawsuit the it was not quite as
complicated of a process so this is this
the uh post lawsuit the rules are a
little bit more complicated which takes
more time and then the issue was
um to staff at a level where we could
um
process applications in a timely fashion
the
um
the other issue we run into is is that
our
um as representative Weiler pointed out
our non-game species program which
includes threatened endangered species
uh is basically runoff donations and we
you know we receive donations and then
we leverage that with Federal funding to
come back and run the program
so
you would be asking you know people to
make donations in order to protect these
species from developers in the state of
New Hampshire we are limited is by rsas
as far as what we can move in from Fish
and Game funds to work on tne species
thank you
very good
um
how healthy is the uh animal population
in the state I mean we you know in
I know we it seems so we got more
incursions of bears I I don't know if
I'm just
I you know I I I know my area we got uh
we got some Wiley uh yogis out there
well
um we're coming off some really good
Seasons we had an excellent deer season
this year we had an excellent um bear
season this year I would say both
populations are doing very well
um I think especially with the deer
population it's not just the numbers
it's the quality of the deer that are
growing right now we have a very I think
we have some of the best deer we've ever
had in the state of New Hampshire right
now really
um
um Colonel Jordan showed me some pitches
on an animal that he confiscated and I
would dare say it's probably the nicest
looking Buck I've ever seen shot in the
state of New Hampshire
um
yeah it was 15 points oh wow and how old
was he Kevin yeah 12 8 or 12. yeah I
think it was I think it was 12. I think
it happened to be one of our biologists
was at the check-in station and looked
at the deer so we actually uh and then
but he didn't pull a tooth but he pulled
a tooth after we confiscated it I think
he was 12 years old but he's a beautiful
beautiful deer so we've had some you
know that you know those areas are good
uh moose population uh we have two
issues with our moose population up
north
um it's
um The Tick issue and then in the
southern part of the state it's the
brain worm here the brain worm is that
CRS uh no uh CW or CW yeah chronic
wasting disease right now that's a
disease in white-tailed deer right now
is that I know it's migrating across the
country it is definitely spreading um
the closest it's come to us it was in
Quebec one of the issues that comes in
with CWD and it's not the only way do
not misunderstand me but
um what happened in Quebec uh they had a
Hunt Club up there where they were
bringing in Farm Deer to augment the
population and unfortunately one of them
had CWD
um I believe I can't I don't know the
details but I'm pretty sure that deer
escaped and the Quebec government
um
try to extinguish the deer population
locally and so far they've been very
successful
um and they haven't found any CWD uh in
any of the wild deer up there New York
state had a case of it same thing they
were able to control it
um it's very hard to control and these
are the only two times any State's been
able to control it
um so the the threat comes from either
importing you know Farm Deer into the
into the state uh Hunter going out west
and bringing back you know uncured
antlers uncured
um
bones I think yeah
um it's a pyron disease so it's very
similar to Scrapy and sheep or mad cow
and cows so so humans can
uh no it's enough different so there's
only there's very few cases of it in
human beings there is some thought that
some indigenous species
I'm sorry sorry
indigenous people
um that have a high venison intake have
have contracted it
um and they're doing some research in
that area but by and large humans don't
scrapeys and sheep do not transfer to
humans mad cow Ken
um they're all closely related and I
apologize
um
I I can't remember the name of the
disease in humans but there is a disease
that's Prime based in humans is very
closely related to all of these is that
one of the duties of biologists to keep
track of all this uh we do
um this year we have had
uh three new Wildlife diseases in the
state of New Hampshire
um I should I apologize two new diseases
in the wildlife in New Hampshire one of
course is even influenza that you read
about we first discovered that in wild
ducks that has since gotten into some
domestic poultry operation poultry
backyard poultry operations in New
Hampshire none of our commercial Farms
have gotten it yet
um
but Nationwide there's been millions and
millions and millions of domestic birds
that have uh had to be put down because
of this it's one of the reasons why
you're now paying seven dollars a dozen
for eggs in a grocery store
um also a reason why y'all paid a little
extra for your turkeys this year too
turkey seem to have at it we had a
problem with it in geese most geese and
Ducks are where we've had it we've had a
large death on Geese
um Kevin what was the one in the deer
yeah yeah I apologize
um but we had a new one that was I think
Webster right yes three three deer were
confirmed with it it's not
um terribly contagious that we're not
terribly concerned about it it's
probably been here for years we just
hadn't picked it up and then
um we're still in the process of testing
but uh our second year test came through
with with no positives but it's we're
pretty certain that we probably would
have we could find covet in our
whitetail deer population
right Whitetail Deer uh have had covet
there has only been one case where they
thought maybe a person caught covered
from a whitetail deer it's very hard to
get the transition back from the deer to
us
and one final question uh
our wild boar population and uh
I I know I believe it's illegal to hunt
I believe they're because they came from
Corbin Park
you know they're they're they're kind of
protected but I know in the past they
were hunted and yeah and you know they
were considered but now they're
considered protected well they're
considered private property
uh the property of the Corbin state park
because what's different with our wild
wild boar here in New Hampshire versus
other states is
um you know quite often what you're
dealing with in most other states are
feral Hogs Hogs that have gotten loose
and constantly reproduced
um what goes on here is some wild boar
that occasionally escaped from the park
there's a lot out there though I mean at
Newport and that area is yes I believe
I've actually hunted them in Newport I
have a friend that Farms there and he's
invited me to his farm before
hmm yeah I know one person that got
quite a few uh I think at least 10 or 11
and they're they're quite the animal
very different than deer you know you
jump a deer you can pick them back up
again in a very short period of time but
bore they take off for the next County
they don't stop I mean they're they're
quite a rototiller yes they are
unbelievable what they how much damage
uh so you I mean is it is it much of an
expense to uh since we're here in
finance we should that's what probably
we should be talking about the expense
to uh or or we just don't do anything I
mean do you have much contact uh
you know in the in the area we no we
it won't
it's not it's it's nowhere near as
widespread you you get in the areas like
Tennessee and places you know Texas or
to Florida and places like that it's a
whole I mean that's a real issue for us
it's it's not there are some impacts
locally for for a few Farmers very close
to the park but other than that it's not
it's it's not a Statewide issue and it's
not it doesn't seem to be spreading very
very well very good thank you anyway
um representative Heath I never
represented all right
well my question goes back to the ask
that you have for the Gopher I I don't
think I quite fully understood it and I
know Mickey I think he wanted to say
something
so so what I think is happening is
the department currently has this
funding available and it's authorized
through June 30. a custom area with any
except an expend item that would go to
the fiscal committee for instance
that money actually will go through
December they're allowed to spend that
so they would have to come back to
fiscal and get a retroactive item back
to July 1st to spend for the first half
of fiscal 24 or you could budget the
federal funds in-house Bill one but if
you didn't want to do that they'd come
to fiscal but what the department is
saying for the second half of fiscal 24
so January through June that's where
they have a shortfall of continuing
oh 25 I'm sorry
the last six months of the biennium
there's a shortfall to complete to fund
those positions that the federal funds
would not cover so that's the request of
representative Murray
thank you again on the fund balance in
you know 22 there's the 11 million which
you know you had a good balance
um you spent that down 23
um it's down again what I'm seeing is
that the
your budgeted estimated revenue is
fairly consistent uh the the
Appropriations
um are fairly consistent so you've been
nipping into the fund balance for the
past three four years
um I have two questions yeah you know
um
yeah and so where did the fund balance
why you know uh
where did the 11 million back in 22 come
from why was there such a healthy
balance then and what is going on either
on the revenue side or the appropriation
side that you have to nip into the
could you come up to the mic no just
come on up to the mic and the director
can answer that if he wants to I'm sorry
I don't want to okay
there's there's two answers to that
actually we have a very healthy balance
in the fish and game fund right now for
a couple of different reasons in fiscal
year 20 and 21 it was brought up here
that we brought in quite a good healthy
amount of licenses and that added to our
unrestricted revenues absolutely
um eleven and a half million a year and
now we're kind of in the downward we
also had a very good lapse at the end of
both of those fiscal years
this um this is kind of an internal
Surplus statement that I do which of
course does not
add a lapse in which historically we
have an eight to a ten percent lapse per
year
so you could add that lapse in as well
and
can I interrupt ask a question you keep
your laps then the laps or oh absolutely
we are self-funded we are the face thank
so
our beginning balance is actually the
highest balance that the fish and game
fund has ever had
historically
Mick you want to say something I was
just going to point the committee to
page 31 of your executive summary from
the governor's recommended budget you'll
see the governor's Surplus statement in
there uh I have identified something in
there that I would need to ask the
governor's office about because it does
talk about a general fund transfer into
the fish and game fund which I don't
believe is actually
happening you've got General funds in
your operating budget corrected it's not
a transfer to the general fund so we'll
talk about that but you will see that
there is over fiscal 23 24 and 25 about
4.2 million dollars of laps estimate
that on Kathy's sheet here is not
reflected it's not reflected so that's
when she's talking about the laps you'll
see the governor's estimate for the laps
anybody else
oh representative thank you
so can cats give give us give us a list
of
um general fund items that that you're
requesting
we're not requesting specific General
funded items that I am aware of
um the general funds are all reflected
within one accounting unit and that is
conservation law enforcement
I don't have my glasses on director
sorry
oh that's in here
I'm sorry I didn't make it really I
didn't mean for you to have to go
searching for this side
I'm kind of scribbled searching for the
glasses you know what I'm I'm scribbling
down here and I was just wanted you to
um confirm that what I had here right we
asked for 139 000 today we've asked for
an additional 139 000 for the aot
program Kevin 170 171 for the two CEOs
each year each year so that's in
addition to what's already in yeah
7887. so can I can I follow up with you
would I scribble down here was on on the
20 uh 24
fiscal 24 996
000 fiscal 25 1.4 million
000 plus
171 is times two yeah 171 extra for 24
and in 25 and then in 25 we need an
additional 139 000 for the 802.
okay sure well okay yeah
no I I have I have these numbers yeah
scribbled down here but
you know I can't read my own
no we we do show the above figures on
page 600. the 996 000 and the 1.49 in
the in the governor's budget these are
in addition to that correct sir so and
it's not unusual to for us to put
General funds in fish and game we were
doing a lot of that before you had your
good years yeah so it you know it's
we've got to keep this this uh agency
healthy whatever it takes and you know
the
there's Ebbs and flows in the in the
demand but nevertheless
they still got to have the staff keep
busy and you know and we got involved
and are asked to do a lot of things that
are not Sportsman related
um for example
in the last biennium
um I don't know if anybody keeps in a
keeps an aquarium but there's and don't
ask me I don't I really understand but
there's something called a moss ball
that you can go to an aquarium store and
buy
and it's a living plant well
unfortunately whoever creates these Moss
balls had water that was contaminated
with zebra mussels
so now all of a sudden you have Moss
ball and a baby zebra muscle you can't
see without a microscope so you as a
customer you would come in and buy that
you could buy that Moss ball and not
know it and then put it in your tank and
then when next time you go clean your
tank and dump it down in the drain
if you live with city city sewer you now
just contaminated your your Municipal
sewer system with with zebra mussels so
it actually fell on fishing game
um
in New Hampshire things are a little
different you know we don't necessarily
have large amounts of money in large
staff all the time so the Department of
Agriculture regulates and inspects
um
uh pet stores
so we worked you know we teamed up with
Department of AG they were able to tell
us who had aquarium equipment and who
didn't and then we sent out our CEOs
because the department of AG didn't have
the authority to talk to them about it
we had to go out and talk to him about
it and we gathered up Moss balls and
hopefully kept kept zebra mussels out
it's a small example but this is what
happens to fish and game and at the end
of the day if you bought a hunting
license or a fishing license you know
municipality should be thanking you
because you just help protect their
sewer systems from Super muscles
but that's what happens
representative Weiler there was another
example I remember that I was surprised
uh people in on Great Bay that have
waterfront property
will come in and ask to have a an oyster
bed approved yeah and at one point we
cut down some funding on Environmental
Services
and they suddenly decided they weren't
going to do a water quality check which
they were required before the fish and
game could issue this permit
and they said no
they cut us they cut us some money so
we're not going to do that anymore
we had to go back to them and said read
the law you will go and check you know
but it was just a way to try to get you
on their side to say you better get give
more money to environmental services
that we won't be able to put out these
permits so if we have little games
played sometimes by some of these
agencies that try to involve somebody
else and I was surprised they they
pulled that but we headed It Off by and
large I would dare say New Hampshire I
think our different agencies are willing
to work together we were talking about
those animal diseases with AI so you had
USDA Animal Control you had New
Hampshire fishing game you had New
Hampshire Department of AG New Hampshire
Health and Human Services and the
University of New Hampshire Diagnostic
lab and all five groups were able to you
know pitch together and and do our
individual tasks and I think
it's not like you could say we're
successful or unsuccessful but we were
certainly willing to cooperate and work
together for the good of the public and
I think that's something to be very
thank you
anybody else
uh representative uh popovichi Miller
thank you and again I apologize for
being out and missing a good part I will
watch it on tape and catch up
um so if any of those questions have
been already asked obviously just tell
me so and I'll watch the tape on it but
I had some notes on various uh budget
Pages starting with uh you know page 560
14-hour budget line zero two seven
560 what sir
564 is the page and the the code is um
zero two seven which is where is it
transfers to oit
my question is you are mentioning the
transfer Studio office and information
technology you are mentioning that you
have database upgrades and projects so I
kind of understand you know the reason
why they're increasing but I just wanted
to check whether that was a temporary or
a permanent Trend I'm assuming you know
part of it is Project I well I
um not to be derogatory to my good
friends at doit but it does seem like
they're but their bill keeps going up
all the time uh I do understand that
they have a horrendous job of protecting
the state
um uh computer systems from hackers and
whatnot so I I don't necessarily
begrudge what we pay but at the same
time it is going up and it is hard for
those agencies that are self-funded it
becomes you know harder and harder for
us to pay those bills as time goes on
the database work we're doing with them
is actually a gopher project and not
part of that budget but in that budget
is we did agree or requested a half a
part-time we're splitting a I.T lead uh
with the veterans hospital is what the
goal is and that I believe that is in in
that added request according to James
Greer at the budget at the governor's
office okay I may send an email and ask
for more detail because it's an increase
of like 240 and uh just want to better
understand where that's part of it is
that is is a is half of a employee
understood yeah and then other and the
rest of it is just they're increasing
costs
got it and then a lot page five six
eight line is zero six four there is a
significant increase in benefits it's
like the two-thirds down the page five
six eight
um if you look in 22 the uh retirement
pension benefits health insurance goes
from 578 to 911 and then to
798 and then to 886
if I could just color on it that's a
self-funded agency we pay the cost of
our retirees health insurance and that
is what that line is
okay so it's based on who signed up for
what plans and the projections on who's
going to be what correct that number is
provided to us by uh the department of
administrative services and that is
based on their projected cost for our
retirees great got it page 571 line 30.
the equipment new replacement
um
that's again a pretty big spike in 23
and then stays at higher levels in 24
and 25.
it's at the top of page 571.
23 is what we're currently budgeted 22
unfortunately we were budgeted the same
amount at a hundred thousand dollars
unfortunately we did not spend it
because people did not put in their
requisitions for a new vehicle because
we can't find them really you're saying
there was a disruption some disruption
in the markets we just received a
vehicle for our hunter education program
that we had a purchase order for for 23
months now I know I know I've been on
the downside and we've had similar
issues even with Cruisers and everything
else it's a nightmare for 24 and 25 that
figure was based on during our uh senior
leadership discussions individual
division Chiefs putting in their request
for vehicle needs this Fleet Management
account is an overall Department Fleet
Management account and it was individual
requests for division for replay
replacement vehicles I understood what
would you say that is a average Baseline
obviously this tends to be noisy because
sometimes you buy vehicles that are ears
when you don't need them so it's really
hard to flatten it but what would you
think is a baseline are we at uh 250 and
200 above the Baseline briefly because
we're trying to catch up for vehicles we
couldn't replace during covid
well this Fleet Management is for
vehicles outside of law enforcement
right okay law enforcement all the other
departments they're in a different
replacement and uh it has nothing to do
with covid really it's quite frankly
because we did not have funding to
replace vehicles for such a long period
of time
we have really overspent on fixing
Vehicles no longer fixable no and it's
not the wise use of resources
yeah it's very inefficient that's that's
great I appreciate it uh then on line
[Music]
bottom of the page
it's again a pretty big increase between
the current levels and the budgeted
levels I'm just trying to understand
again the
need for it game management is one of
our dedicated accounts and
um
the best person to answer this would be
Dan Bergeron who was the chief of
wildlife but it is my understanding that
this would be used for contracts for
ow um
for additional detail to be mailed to
the committee that would be much
appreciated I certainly will do that
thank you and let's see next we are a
page 581 line033
uh third down the page land Acquisitions
and easement
that one is again a bit spiky and I'm
just trying to understand what's going
on so it's going from 260 to 500 and
then it is budgeted at 350. just some
this is another dedicated account and
our apportionments for PR funds has been
Pittman Robinson funds has steadily been
increased on the federal level and to
take advantage of that we try to ensure
that we have enough money appropriated
in the budget should the opportunity to
be able to purchase a good piece of land
Avail itself
um not always is that opportunity there
land acquisition is unpredictable by
Nature sometimes you think you're gonna
close and the day of the close turns out
you don't yeah that's correct but
basically the intent of those funds is
to also get matching funds from the feds
so it's a way to leverage our dollar and
hopefully get some more absolutely as a
matter of fact if you look down at the
funding component especially in fiscal
year to uh in in all the fiscal years if
you look down at the funding component
the increase is in the federal funds
yeah and actually the federal funds
Trend now that you point to it tends to
mirror the trend in our budget it's so I
can see the correlation there
great
um
let's see go ahead it's actually a
little different as far as the federal
funds on this particular item Federal
money comes from the excise tax on the
sale of guns ammunition and hunting
equipment so if folks have been reading
the newspapers or participating you know
that gun and ammunition sales have been
going up steadily over the last few
years so we're actually receiving we're
actually eligible for more Federal money
in the last few years it's gone up
fairly dramatically
um now the normal match is a 25-75 match
but we can do other things to come up
with our 25 match like if we have a
piece of land that does not have already
have a federal incumbency accumbens on
it we can use that land and put a
federal you know put the federal lien on
it and then and then we can use that as
part of our match so sometimes it's not
necessarily just a cash that we do but
that does play out you know there's a
lot of ups and downs in this the other
thing we can do is work with another
partner and and use their cash for match
in order to achieve some of these land
purchases fully understood and I'm even
gonna refrain from harping on how
certain sales are good for the economy
on the same page line 304 deals with
research and management again a similar
in this particular unit the wildlife
habitat Wildlife program
same type of situation with UNH and the
research and it's the same type of
situation where there is a desire to
grow the habitat program
I I would again I would appreciate some
feed follow-up later on exactly what's
the nature of the program and how it
benefits us absolutely and I apologize
for asking so many questions but you
know it's my first term and I have a lot
to learn about every agency and I really
appreciate you providing all this one of
the things is Our Land base increases
the costs of maintaining that land base
obviously is going up so we are spending
more money on on those issues some of
the issues are just keeping roads
repaired and whatnot we also manage the
land for hat wildlife habitat so we're
in doing uh forestry cuts and works like
that and then we also end up having to
spend money on defending uh property
just like any landowner property
boundaries Etc markings you know signing
and signage and whatnot cool so if we
could go to page 589 just two more this
is two more questions five or page 589
line 103. is that the um
trailers Bureau New transfer that you
were talking about the increase transfer
or no that is not that is actually uh
the line for contracts oh sorry I
I must have gotten you the wrong number
zero four nine I just wrote the wrong
line
is the increase in transfers to the
trails Bureau I thought so but again you
know I'd rather double check I don't
want to assign two millions to the wrong
reason and the last question on page 597
line 307 about the Statewide Public boat
access
at two-thirds down the page
it's again if you look at the expense
it's uh you know 800 000 in the previous
year 100 now and then evens out to 400
any color as to why the swings uh are
happening
fiscal year 22 was a major project
called downing's Landing up on Lake
Winnipesaukee that's why that very large
expanse and you can also see the
corresponding federal funds for that
um I'm not sure if Garrett is
anticipating some big projects yeah
um so the two aspects of this program
one is the maintenance on our boat
Landings and that would be obviously
kind of steady or hopefully more steady
obviously sometimes winter damage or
storm damage does create or or even
erosion or sediment deposits create some
extra management for us
um beyond that is when we're actually
building a new boat landing in a new
location so uh downing's Landing was on
a very southern tip of Alton Bay
um and we were very fortunate a few
years back to be able to buy that piece
of property and they had been working on
it and we finished up that project uh
in that fiscal year
um this year he's got two uh uh Garrett
is our boat landing guy and he's got two
uh projects that he is looking at doing
over the next couple fiscal year of the
next two fiscal years that he's he's
trying to do one
um is a project on the Connecticut River
I think in Claremont but I'm not 100
sure and then he's got another one down
in Raymond he's looking at God knows
Claremont can use some help you know
here and there
um I used to be at Dartmouth College and
there is a wonderful paragliding
facility in Claremont but that's really
my entire experience with the area so I
really appreciate you taking all the
time and again I apologize for just
having a long batch of questions lined
up but I had to step out and I
appreciate it thank you
representative Kathy before she
before she sits down
um
so
how much additional funding does the
department need in above above the
really confer
to this meeting about that
well so so the extra money would be
those that we already went over for
General funding and then Kathy's
position would be extra funding and I
don't have that figure but that would be
coming out of the fish and game fund
that's approximate at least sixty five
thousand dollars in each year of the by
any
I just want authority to to create that
thank you very much for your time
okay
yeah it's yeah I mean it's we we know
I don't have a gavel but
that's a virtue that's a virtual gavel
and uh welcome to
finance division two the best division
in uh Finance
well good afternoon Mr chair
um honorable members of division two uh
my name is Robert Quinn and I'm the
commissioner of the Department of Safety
and with me today is Mr Steve Lavoy the
director of administration today we will
present the governor's recommended FY
24-25 budget for the Department of
Safety I am pleased to report that the
governor's budget funds all existing
Services required to maintain Public
Safety in New Hampshire through FY 24
and 25. the mission of the Department of
Safety is to continually enhance the
safety security and quality of life in
New Hampshire through professional
collaborative and Innovative service to
all I am honored to lead our dedicated
team of Professionals in the department
of safety and proud of how each division
works day in and day out to ensure that
Public Safety Services are delivered
across the state demand for Public
Safety Services continues to increase
salary and benefit increases combined
with equipment replacement costs and
growing Reliance on I.T infrastructure
and systems have contributed to an
overall increase in providing the same
level of these critical services
throughout the presentation today we
will focus how remaining prioritized
needs will impact delivery of Public
Safety Services across New Hampshire we
recognize that state funds are limited
and respectfully requests your
consideration be given to those items
during the house phase of the budget
process director Lavoy will now spend
time discussing the governor's budget
request at the division level and
provide a summary of changes current
funding gaps and any expected impacts on
Services we're happy to take any
questions that you might have throughout
the presentation thank you and thank you
Steve
great thank you commissioner good
afternoon everybody so we've got a
presentation that you've got a copy of
here in front of you and what we tried
to do here is really summarize our
budget I mean there's so many pages in
that document to pull it together and
highlight the major changes in the major
areas that you're seeing so on page two
just as a reminder from the last time
that we met we're structured into seven
divisions within the department of
safety each of these divisions has a
unique funding mix and funding source
and so because of that it really makes
sense for us to kind of consider the
needs at the division level instead of
department-wide and so the seven bureaus
are I'm sorry seven divisions are listed
there and their primary responsibilities
on page three we do start with a summary
for the Department as a whole so this is
extremely high level and we'll go into
more detail by division in the following
pages but the 24-25 request so in 2024
the department of safety budget is
249.3 million dollars and in 25 it's
250.5 million dollars that is an
increase from FY 23 of about 15 in total
you can see the different fund mixes
that are provided there look at the
green are the general funds so in FY 24
there's 53.9 million in general funds in
an fy25 55.6 million there's all the
other funding sources summarized below
as well Highway funds cost of
collections which are the revenues that
we collect at the DMV and the road toll
before they hit the highway fund
Turnpike funds that support some of our
state police operations and then several
dedicated funds that fall into the other
source those dedicated funds we look at
Revenue projections and make sure that
we have the funding available to to meet
those appropriation requests that we
have in the budget and then finally we
have federal funds as well and a lot of
the federal funds that we receive are
passed through to other state agencies
and other local entities but there are
some that support our operations as well
especially in Homeland Security
authorized full-time positions to the
right here we have
1143 classified and 13 unclassified
positions there are 34 unfunded
full-time positions uh within this at
this time and some of those include new
positions that we requested through the
agency phase um so we'll discuss those
uh with you as we go through the
presentation today
as far as significant changes for 24 and
12.1 million of the increase from 23 and
9.1 million in 25 is due to operating
costs that have increased including
replacement equipment supplies
facilities contracts we've just seen
prices go up across the board there's
also some increased volume of activity
that we need equipment we need to
replace because we weren't able to in
previous biennium because of supply
chain shortages and because of funding
constraints so there's some opportunity
for us to gain ground and make sure that
we don't run into future problems with
our equipment replacement plans
8.9 million of the increase in 24 and
8.3 million of the increase in 25 are
due to increases in federal funds the
majority of those are disaster Grant
reimbursements the state and local
agencies so like I said pass-through
funds in two other areas
5.7 million of the increase in 24 and
6.7 and 25 are due to change in
budgeting uh required by administrative
services this resulted in double
budgeting risk and benefit costs so that
they're recorded within the divisions
and those funding sources where we're
going to pay for those out of but we
have a single accounting unit where the
actual expenditures out to das are also
reflected so it's not truly an increase
it's just the way that we're accounting
for this this biennium
and finally 3.9 million of the increase
in 24 and 25 are due to increases in
doit costs these are a major I.T systems
as the commissioner mentioned
investments in I.T are critical and they
continue and that's the increased costs
are are being driven up we also have
shared doit services that have increased
as well and those are recorded in here
and part of that
so in total General Highway Turnpike
cost of collections funding so what we
kind of call the state funding section
increased by 9.2 million or seven
percent in FY 24 and 3.1 million or two
percent in fy25 and that's as the
commissioner mentioned that's providing
the same level of service that's really
what this budget's built around
other funding sources increased by 10.1
million and 24 which is 17 and that was
due to a change in accounting as we
mentioned before and the overall Rising
costs and within this budget uh
presentation we'll talk about eight
civilian positions that are unfunded uh
and new nine new positions that are also
unfunded that are required to meet
increased demands for service that the
public have
there are 17 Trooper positions that are
unfunded within the governor's budget
but these 17 positions were unfunded in
the previous biennium and they were
unfunded in the biennium before that as
well and so we want to make everyone
aware that they're not funded
um but we would be funding current
levels of service if we wanted to expand
the levels of service we would need
so we'll move on to the division level
starting with the office of the
commissioner on page four
the office of the commissioner's budget
request for fy24 is 20.1 million it's
actually a three percent decrease from
the FY 23 budget
the decrease is due primarily to a
transfer of Debt Service expenditures
that were recorded within this area but
we transfer those out into special
expenses account because of challenges
we had with the fund mixes within that
particular accounting unit
the office of the commissioner has 45
classified and three unclassified
full-time positions there are no
unfunded positions within within this
unit
and the office of the commissioner is
provides oversight over some direct
areas including the Bureau of hearings
which conducted 14 343 hearings in FY 22
the office of Highway Safety which
Awards 886 thousand dollars in
additional support to 81 local police
departments that's for additional
patrols enhanced Patrols an illegal unit
which provides legal services to all the
divisions within the Department of
Safety
so the significant changes we talked
about the decrease no significant
changes in salaries and benefits there
is a slight increase of 340 K and 25 due
to
increases in the general services and
risk benefit costs
and there's no prioritized needs as we
mentioned in this area
moving on to page five the division of
administration
division of administration's budget
request for FY 24 is 12.2 million this
is a four percent increase over 23.
12.5 million and 25 which is a three
percent increase
there are 85 classified and two
unclassified positions uh within this
division
there's one unfunded full-time position
but that's a new position that we're
requesting this year so all of our
existing positions are fully funded
the division collected in FY 22 over 181
million dollars in road toll revenues
they conducted 108 audits of road toll
licensees processed over 1.8 million
pieces of incoming mail and 1.3 million
pieces of outgoing mail and distributed
567 000 license plates and 1.8 million
plate decals to municipalities and DMV
substations across the state
and the division is uh
62 percent of the costs that you're
seeing here are related to Personnel
um
in
the main changes we have on the summary
of significant changes in the division
of administration 162 000 of the
increase in 24 and 386 000 be increased
in 25 are due to salary and benefit
increases from increments
260 000 of the increase in 24 and 272 of
the increase in 25 are due to the doit
expenses that are increasing then those
benefit the department as a whole and
many of those are recorded within this
division
and then we also transferred three
existing facilities positions from other
divisions within the department into the
facilities management Bureau to ensure
effective oversight and consistent
delivery of services and so that's
reflected that change is reflected in
this budget as well
there is one prioritized need that's
impacting this Division and that's the
request for a new human resource
coordinator too to assist in the Human
Resources Bureau that Bureau is
responsible for all the transactions
employee pay benefits new hires
also any any risk issues as far as ADA
requirements
and so uh
essentially the the the current
structure doesn't allow us to be timely
with a lot of these requests this
position would be required to ensure
that we can turn those around timely
and ensure that there's no errors we can
mitigate errors that might negatively
page six is the Division of Motor
Vehicles
the Division of Motor Vehicles request
for fy24 is 32.5 million dollars and for
FY 25 is 33.1 million dollars that's
about a six percent increase from 23 for
24.
there are 208 classified and two
unclassified full-time positions within
the division there are six unfunded
positions within the DMV
the service highlights for FY 22 the DMV
issued 405 167 motor vehicle titles
formed 36 219 road tests produced 381
497 driver license and ID cards
processed over 1.6 million Motor Vehicle
registrations and fielded 412 336
summary of significant changes for fy24
2.5 million of the increase in 24 and
2.7 of the increase in 25 are directly
related to doit costs for the
maintenance of the vision and map
systems those are the DMV subsystems
that all transactions are processed
through and those need to be maintained
to ensure that they don't
um
they don't go obsolete we need to make
sure things are are always functioning
1 million decrease in FY 24 and 379 000
decrease in 25 are due to salary and
benefit expenses there's four unfunded
positions that are impacting the new
employees
and 475 000 of the increase in contracts
for operational Services due to costs
associated with relocating the Epping
DMV
um to a lease space so that's uh that
that is a new item within this budget
the current uh Epping DMV is located in
the troop station in the building that
houses The Troop station in Epping as
well and that location around that area
has started to grow and it's been
challenging to get
um in and out of that of that parking
lot quite frankly and so driving exams
getting people to
um to get back out onto the road has
been a challenge and they've begun to
outgrow the space too can't keep the
customers in line the lines are getting
longer so one of the models at the DMV
that we've been successful in is moving
to lease space which allows them to grow
and constrict as needed based on volume
the most recent facility was Keen so
Keane moved out of the troop station
into lease space
about a year or so ago and So within
this budget are the funds necessary to
somewhere within the area don't know
exactly we'd have to yeah yeah well
question uh representative Murray
thank you um the proprietorized needs
they're quite they're you know quite
modest
um but I'm still curious can you speak
to
efficiencies that you've seen with doing
more stuff online and is there more
things are there more things that you
can do online that you're looking at in
sure I'll try with one recently I know
that they um
they had been working on efficiency to
register commercial vehicles and I know
that I recently read something from the
DMV where they were able to process I
believe the largest trucking company in
the state in one day due to their online
and due to their improvements which
would have taken I believe several weeks
so
um you know they've they've really moved
forward with with some areas of the
commercial they've been focused on that
and they've got other other areas in the
in the queue and I think you know
director Lavoy can can speak to one area
where he's looking at with the the
license plates and the decals and the
process that we're trying to Target to
yeah so um the IRP registration was was
huge so that was something that used to
happen internally with our staff over
several weeks and um that was now able
to happen with the company themselves
through the online portal with our
assistance uh within within hours so
those are those are big efficiencies
um the the efficiency the commissioner
is speaking to is I mentioned the plate
room functions in the division of
administration
um we have uh we're looking at
modernizing that inventory system and
moving to a push instead of a pull
inventory we sh we know what type of
plates and the volumes that the
municipalities have historically and so
we should be able to forecast and
deliver those ahead of time instead of
waiting for them to run low and relying
on on them to make sure that their
inventory counts are are adequate so um
so we have funding that we've received
for that
um
Federal through go for funding so arpa
funds and we're working on that type of
project right uh on the on the irps now
is there an intermediary company that uh
does it for the in other words they they
grew because they need obviously to be
registered across the country and
usually a company another company
no they can they've done it themselves
they're doing it themselves okay so
that's what's nice the IRP program
itself allows them to register here and
then um conduct business across the
country oh okay yeah thank you
representative Heath thank you Mr chair
thank you for answering my question
um
oit seems to be of all the budgets I've
heard they're tired and higher and
higher now are they accommodating all
these upgrades that you're doing or do
you have to hire other people to come in
it's a mix
um
they they do whatever they can they're
our first stop so we we try to utilize
doit and the Staffing the services that
they have
um whenever we can but sometimes some of
these systems are just so large in scope
that doit can't support us and can't
help us develop it in those cases we do
go external with with contractors now
does dot doit help you find contractors
that will assist you in promoting the
best possible options yes they're
they're fully engaged in the whole
process from procurement through
Contracting through day-to-day
management so they're being managed by
doit on our behalf great thank you and
I'll just add to that too they um we
have a standing meeting our directors
with the doit team
our point of contact has been very
helpful he guides us he leads through
these you know below commissioner Goulet
but the support that I see from doit is
is fantastic
representative Murray now thank you for
your patience what does IRP stand for
see ya yep
um the international registration
program and it's International because
it includes the provinces up in Canada
as well
and the other thing I so director
morasko at the DMV he has a lot of
projects in the air one of the other
things he's looking at now is e-title
and e-lean you know moving those to an
electronic phase so again it takes a
project a document project management
you need the right team in there you
need the funding and um and they they do
it the right way some of these things
take time but at the end um it it's got
and and as far as the vehicles uh in the
enforcement portion of it are we see in
the trucks in better shape or I mean how
how is that how is that going as far as
well financially as well as the number
of trucks that you have to cite
you know that that no not me I'm not
roadworthy sure you know I I don't think
I'm prepared to answer that question
today I mean part of Troop G is the
commercial enforcement section but I
will say this they have a tremendous
relationship with the industry so that
we educate and they all understand the
importance of safety uh the inspection
um the whole issue with commercial
drivers and CDL we just worked on a on a
on a video a professional video on
preparing them on the pre-trip the test
so that they can really focus on safety
and um so I think I can't tell you here
how many right I would say that the
industry and the enforcement uh arm of
the State Police have a very close
relationship
thank you
foreign
so moving on to the prioritized needs
for the Division of Motor Vehicles there
are four existing data control clerk
three positions and these are these are
vacant currently but they are positions
we we do have budgeted in 2223 and that
we typically have filled and they're
they're they're critical in ensuring
that we process driver history record
accident Data Ticket payments um and
making sure there's no delays in that
area the other piece is an increase in
credit card fees so we've seen more
credit card usage as we continue to move
online for services
right now the department does not charge
a convenience fee for use of a credit
card and because of that we need
additional funding to to cover those
costs
we may be in a position to start
charging a convenience fee because we're
seeing so much growth in this area and
that's something we're talking about
internally
if we don't have this funding it would
really Force us into that that decision
representative thank you Mr do you need
any Authority for that or is that within
your purview so that's within our
purview we have the authority by Statute
to make that to make that decision thank
you
um
DMV security enhancements so this is a
priority of the the director
um the this funding would allow the DMV
to install protective glass at the
counters across the state and then also
hire part-time security monitors at the
higher volume locations there's been
issues that we've had at certain
locations where customers you know can
get upset
um and and we want to make sure that our
employees feel secure and comfortable uh
it's a retention issue really as well as
we're always trying to make sure that we
hire the right people and get them to
stay so that's that that's an important
an important need at this point
and then finally the uh opening a new
DMV substation in the Plymouth area so
right now individuals who live in The
Lakes Region have the choice to go to
Concord or up to Tamworth in either case
it's it's it's a drive the wait lines in
both of those areas are start you know
are pretty steady and they're starting
to increase as there's more people
living in and around the Lakes Region
area a Plymouth area location would
would help to alleviate that demand and
representative uh
okay thank you Mr chairman
um if we open the Plymouth will Tamworth
stay open
Yeah Tim would would stay open there's
still a need for services in that area
you know we recognize before any
decisions that made customer services is
a priority too but the prior question if
we're not in Epping where would it be
you know we're aware that services are
available in Dover and and Salem but in
Manchester about what you know how do we
not impact customers and reduce the
okay so uh moving on to the division of
I'm sorry I forgot to ask this question
before
um
in in the cost of collections
in the yellow bars here where it says 30
million
is that come off the top of Highway
funds first correct yep yep before so
the any of the revenues collected from
DMV transactions
um before that money gets deposited into
the highway fund uh the costs for that
period of time
um are covered through this cost thank
you
the division of State Police on page
seven the budget request for foi 24 is
114 million which is a 10 increase from
FY 23 and then for fy25 is
113.4 million
the division of State Police have 578
classified in one unclassified full-time
position there are 21 unfunded positions
but as I mentioned 17 of those are
troopers from previous uh previous
biennium that have not been funded
recently but there are some positions
and we'll talk about those that are new
positions that we're we're asking for
consideration
in FY 22 State Police Stopped 74 671
Motor Vehicles arrested 753 impaired
drivers conducted 6299 criminal
investigations conducted 106 446
commercial vehicle inspections and
weight checks they process 69 569 sets
um the summary of significant changes
for the division 4.2 million of the
increase in 24 and 3.8 million of the
increase in 25 is due to increased costs
for replacement equipment including
portable radios and fleet vehicles the
fleet vehicle replacement plan has
really never been fully funded
and it's limited our ability to ensure
that we have a healthy Fleet so at this
point we have high mileage vehicles that
are often breaking down and need repair
and our repair costs are going up and
finding spare Vehicles is also a
challenge and the key here is that a
trooper without a vehicle can't perform
their their function we want to make
sure Troopers stay on the road as much
as possible and not because of be off
the road because of equipment concerns
So within this budget we do have 70
vehicles that are be funded replacement
vehicles in 24 and 76 and 25
that helps to make a dent but then there
there's a it doesn't help us meet our
Target to get to our Target there is
money in House Bill 2 to purchase an
additional 52 vehicles for state police
that will reset and bring us back to
where we need to to have a fleet that's
healthy that we can maintain with our
existing repair staff and we'll start to
see decreases in our maintenance costs
moving forward as well representative
Weiler thank you what's the total number
of state troopers on the road with
vehicles we have 360 uh Troopers so each
Trooper would need a vehicle and then
our Target is to have 400 Vehicles which
gives us the the 40 spare so we can make
sure everyone stays on the road
I remember when it was 200.
probably probably the director does too
how much if I may uh how much more is a
vehicle today say than five years ago I
mean give you know this
you know it because it it seems like
they're on a steep climb as far as the
cost and what what is it today versus
yeah so so we we're budgeting between 65
and 75 uh per vehicle that's full fit up
so that's the vehicle plus
um lights radio paint everything to put
it into service
um so I I don't have the exact amount of
what yeah I mean I'm looking for you
know I'm looking for the it's been it's
been increasing we used to budget uh
closer to you know in the 50 to 60 range
and now we're we're at 65 75 range so
and and can you get these vehicles now I
mean well that's the that's the trick
that that's the issue so even in the
prior years when we had funding for
Replacements we weren't able to purchase
as many as we had intended because the
manufacturing lines shut down
um it's it's a supply chain issue we
can't guarantee we're able to but we
need to make sure we have the
Appropriations to give us the
opportunity
um otherwise we're always going to be
chasing our tail and I will tell you I I
meet with the state police that are
assigned to managing that there's
actually a woman that oversees that and
as quick as we can get the car carriers
in and get the vehicles transported down
so they are they are like on top of it
and it's just a matter of getting us in
and once the vehicles get in they wait
till they get them all so that they
paint them all at once and they start
upfitting them and it's a process and we
do everything we can so that we stay you
know so to speak at the top of the line
and we're not holding them up at all so
it really is a it's it's impacting
you'll see law enforcement across the
country but we're doing everything we
can and I and I and I know that they are
representative Murray
yeah thank you I think I heard you say
that there's 52 new vehicles listed in
hb2 and that would get you fully
functional right
um going forward what do you need to
maintain full functionality did will
this go down because you have 52 new
vehicles and so going forward I would
assume that there would be less requests
for that
so I'll I'll take a little stab so I
mean Steve's got a financial and a
strategic
um
thought process but if you have so many
Troopers you can really look at what is
our vehicle replacement plan and they've
looked at that knowing how many miles
they might put on a year at one point is
it diminishing returns of you know
fixing the vehicles they can they can
build into that how many unfortunately
might be involved in a crash per year
but really they can look at it and they
have the metrics too how do we want to
budget you know
I would say conservatively but to not
impact Public Safety and and I know that
Steve Works closely with that so it
really is based on Miles and
unanticipated crashes mechanical failure
but that's that's really how we do
overall budget for the fleet
you're spot on and I mean I I'll give
you a range of numbers I don't want to
commit to a number
um obviously because of all those
variables but we'll be backed into the
normal requests when I say normal
um anywhere from the 40 to 50 vehicle
range per year instead of the 70 to 100
vehicle range per year so that's that
factors in about a dozen crashes that
end up in a total vehicle every year
um
aging out for mileage at about 150 130
150 000 mile range
um making sure we have those spare
vehicles that are functioning so you'd
see you would see
requests that mirrored prior years
so moving on to the summary of
significant changes 2.2 million of the
increase and 1.7 in 24 and 1.7 of the
increase in 25 are due to increased
operating expenses this is mainly fuel
vehicle maintenance and repair costs
again we talked about costs increasing
across the board and that's reflected
here
1.1 million of the increase in 24 and
888 000 of the increase in 25 are due to
increased costs for it systems so here's
our doit expenses again this is
computer-aided dispatch and the records
management system and then also
maintenance of the state's message
platform and that's used to pass
criminal justice information to the
different recipients across the state
the program you might have heard of is
J1 the system that ensures that we're
communicating with the courts and
Corrections and DMV and State Police so
that platform has to stay up and running
right so so how much more is it costing
you for cyber security I mean is it a
tax more
more prevalent now I mean what
it seems so that you hear a lot about
that in the news uh these you know
agencies being attacked and you know it
and and of course we see doit costs are
skyrocketing as my in my opinion sure
well I think that I mean Steve can we
can speak to it but we have invested in
training in some infrastructure we work
closely with the oit on cyber security
but you know the impact on us the cost
um they work very hard to protect our
data and have the proper firewalls of
the state network but it's something
that you absolutely have to pay
attention to and continue to
um to invest to stay current if you've
ever put a number to that you know the I
mean it's we've there's been some recent
Grant dollars that have been put forward
to advancing cyber security but Steve
you know yeah I think
um
you could put a number to it but it
wouldn't be accurate because it's
involved in everything that we're doing
now and so doit is considering cyber
security risk and factoring that into
new contracts to new vendors to the
network itself which equipment are they
purchasing and why how are they setting
it up and so you can't really extract
the true cost there but like the
commissioner mentioned there's there's
Federal money through Homeland Security
that's being made available now
um in fact when we get to House Bill 2
you will see there's a matching
component that's appropriated to to
support the state's share of the of the
federal funds for that program which is
really looking Statewide and for
government at state and local levels on
how can we improve cyber security at all
levels of government
but but to put a just a single dollar
so 2.7 million of the increase in 24 and
3.9 million of the increase in 25 for
the division of State Police are due to
increases in risk and benefit amounts
that's retiree health workers comp
Property and Casualty Insurance
and then finally 630 000 of the increase
in funding
um is
specific to part-time auxiliary Troopers
and so that's to ensure that we fully
fund the part-time Troopers that we have
currently
um to address ongoing demands for for
question uh thank you um I think the
last time we were here we talked a
little bit about the difficulty of
getting employees so I guess they have
two questions one how big was your lapse
up for an inability to hire employees
and how are you doing enticing people to
um become state troopers
the lapse sure so so on back on page
three
um we show the overall lapse by fun
um the vast majority of that is salary
and benefits I mean there there were
some because of equipment costs like I
mentioned but it's really it the
vacancies have been significant I mean
there were there was a point where we
were over 20 as a department
um we're far better now we're around 16
the last time
um that that we got the reporting out
and that and that varies by division
there's some divisions that are worse
there's than 16 there's some divisions
that are lower
um but we're starting to see more
applicants
and and that's the big change so six
months ago we weren't even seeing a
large number of applicants for positions
now we're seeing applicants and and now
we're able to bring people in and have
discussions we they may or may not be
the right applicants but we're starting
to see applicants the pay raise will
help pay raise will help significantly I
mean that that that's the issue uh we're
trying to recruit we're trying to
incentivize people uh we have some some
things that were that were incentives
that we've had passed for Troopers for
law enforcement we have referral bonuses
for civilian employees and we're always
talking internally at talk talk to your
friends talk to your family who's
looking for work but it's the pet and it
always comes back they're they're not
representative Buco thank you Mr
chairman
um we we have not had to lower our
standards in order to attract people
have we no I will say this Colonel noise
has a fantastic team uh he is the leader
of the New Hampshire State Police I'm
seeing a lot of positive movement there
and I do see you know since some changes
have been made we are not seeing uh the
resignations
um which is really important and there's
a lot of uh interest and excitement in
joining his team and he he has not uh
and nor will they ever
um make any significant changes their
standards so I'm very um
very pleased with what we're seeing now
this is an issue Nationwide but they're
making Improvement in uh and they're
I think so I you know and I I travel
across country quite a bit and I'll tell
you our state trooper is probably the
best in the country you know and of
course we have to retrain them after
they go to California like well I want I
want to thank you for saying it well
it's you know it's I mean we got the
best I mean they the vehicles look nice
I mean you know we you can be proud of
what we have well thank you I'll convey
so page eight lists the prioritized
needs for the division of State Police
so first uh and again the first two
items are new positions the first one is
a new criminalist one positions within
the lab
two of these are within the forensic
biology unit and that's an area that um
demand has more than tripled since 2012
and it's really an area that's
understaffed we are implementing new
technologies in that area to help speed
up the processing but we still need
individuals to analyze the results
and these are the the positions that we
would need there is a third criminalist
position and that would be required in
the toxicology lab and that's to address
increased demand for services and
testing for for drug samples especially
as the substances continue to evolve and
change and the the testing is not
declining in that area
there's a program specialist three which
is a new position in the traffic Bureau
within the digital evidence unit and
this is the unit that was created with
the rollout of the body camera
program and dash cameras and so when
we're generating video evidence
um there's an increased demand for
copies of that evidence and we can't
just turn video over unscrubbed and so
you need to redact things that shouldn't
people don't need to see and go through
that process and as that increases we
need additional resources who can who
can perform that function for state
police
and then lastly the 1.6 million each
year these are those 17 positions that
had been previously unfunded so if these
were funded this would allow us to
expand patrols
um but in the current budget we're
maintaining at the existing levels of
service I just want to add going back to
the top you know director Lavoy spoke of
new technologies in the lab I just want
to say that these are significant this
will advance the capabilities of DNA
testing and we'll um will support
victims in the future so it is really
really
exciting what they're doing in there
representative mother thank you Mr chair
just a quick question on the
additional positions that you want to
increase the safety Patrols
they were unfunded because you you know
were unable to hire people or they were
just unfunded and if we do you know
allocate those funds what's your
confidence in being able to hire the
people to implement the patrols
so that that's a good question I and I
think I think what director Lavoy has
tried to do is just keep those there and
put those there those are unfunded I
want to say
yeah those have been unfunded for many
many budget Cycles so I mean my my focus
is on primarily the positions that we're
looking for now and the colonel has a
plan to um what we've asked for that we
think we can fill them uh over the next
two years but these I think it's
important that everyone's aware that at
one point they were there
um and if it's just for awareness but I
don't want to over commit that we could
fill all of those positions but we are
committing to the positions we've asked
for in the budget thank you
representative Murray
ah thank you again I can I propose the
um the traffic Bureau the program
specialist can you speak just generally
around privacy issues and how
um those body camera videos
are you know the security around those
devices and uh just because this has
been in the news fairly recently
um do the Troopers carry their own cell
phones or is that not allowed in terms
of because you know they're I'm
referring to incidents where police have
used their cell phones to you know video
some sort of an incident and then it
goes out into the public and you just
speak to us about how you address that
sure well with with the body cameras and
the cruiser cameras this unit
um just to keep it simple they follow
the law so there's a law that um really
guides what is you know what can be
released what can't be released how it
is used in a criminal case
um we are continually looking to ensure
my goal would be to have every state
trooper have a cell phone have a state
issued phone so we are we are looking at
that right now and and I believe it's
important that if they have that they
have that equipment that that can be
I also understand that everybody needs
their own phone if they have to get
contacted by their or exactly your loved
ones you know speaking of phones uh your
your signal around the state are you
pretty much all covered now as far as
your radios in the cars
you know that that is a great question
and what I what I will tell you is this
we have a Statewide interoperability
coordinator Mr John Stevens that works
over on Smokey Bear Boulevard he's
attached to the division of emergency
services and Communications which
oversees the entire Statewide Network
and what they continually do is they
have Engineers that test this that are
responsive and then we look to see what
what we're hearing from the Troopers are
there gaps they do the continual testing
then they will take that and they'll
work with the engineers to see where and
how we may fill these gaps I will say
four to six years they have made
significant improvements with that not
only in improvements but in the
continual
oversight and full Envision to where
this needs to go what needs to be
replaced when and why and um so I think
I think it's I think there are still
gaps
in certain places and now they're trying
you know some of these gaps may be in
remote areas where there's no
electricity or it's a little harder to
put a tower but in many areas they look
and say we can leverage this existing
Tower this existing equipment and fill
that Gap in some areas it's training you
might not be able to communicate on one
channel but on the other and again I am
not the the radio expert but I will say
that we have a team that maintains it
and we have folks that are working to uh
at a higher level with the engineers
right Steve you know yeah I know I I
mean I don't really have anything to add
to that other other than even changes in
technology help and that's the team that
we have now are always looking at that
and I know recently they were able to
um install new technology new equipment
on existing Towers to address gaps in
the western part of the state things
that weren't available five years ago
and so it's constantly evolving it's
constantly something that that
good
okay
um moving on to page nine this is the
division of Homeland Security and
hscm's budget request for fy24 is 27.4
million for fy25 26.9 million
significant increase from FY 23.
obviously it's almost 56 increase and
that's due primarily to the disaster
funding
um that we spoke about earlier and so
these are
the disbursements of funds from previous
disasters including covid which are
going to continue into the next biennium
and so these would be reimbursements
passing through Homeland to locals
um that that have to be budgeted
the division of Homeland Security has 42
classified and two unclassified
full-time positions there are two
unfunded full-time positions that are
existing vacant positions that are here
in prioritized needs
in FY 22 the division activated the
state Emergency Operations Center 10
times they facilitated 16 exercises and
67 trainings conducted 31 initial
reviews and approved 44 local Hazard
mitigation plans for locals and they
awarded 35 Emergency Management
performance grants to locals across the
state
the summary of significant changes for
24.25 1.9 million dollars of the
increase in 24 an additional 2.2 million
and 25 is due to increase in salary and
benefits including Federal disaster
Grant funded temporary full-time
positions this was a change in approach
that the division took over the last uh
over the last biennium and that's
ensuring that we fully utilize the
management costs that come with these
federal funds to hire full-time
temporary federally funded roles to do
the administrative work instead of
absorbing that with our state funded
positions and so it's the right
direction to go but that's part of the
reason why there is an increase here too
7.4 million dollars with the increase in
24 are due to increased Federal disaster
money distributed to State and local
disaster responses
there are seven open disasters and as I
mentioned those remain open until all
the bills are paid and so we need to
make sure we have the Appropriations to
pass those funds through
78 000 of the increase in FY 24 and 80
000 in FY 25 is funding a new
radiological instrument technician
position that's in the radiological
instrument maintenance and calibration
section this was at the request of
Seabrook station and these positions
um it's funded by Seabrook station 100
through the assessment that um
that we Bill them and these are the
positions that actually calibrate and
test the radiological detection
equipment within the epz
he prioritize needs a position that we
mentioned there's two positions one is a
program specialist one and the other is
a program Assistant two and these are
really required to conduct all of the
functions at Homeland Security they help
with training and exercise they're
responding to radiological emergency
preparedness inquiries they're
processing reimbursements reporting of
federal draws of the complete
complete functions within Homeland
Security and those are existing
positions that are vacant
but have been filled over the last
biennium
page 10 is the division of emergency
services and Communications
the request for
division of emergency services and
Communications for FY 24 is 18.5 million
dollars which is a 5 increase over 23.
and for 25 is 18.9 million dollars which
is a two percent increase
the division has 130 classified and one
unclassified employee there are no
unfunded positions and no prioritized
needs
this is a division that runs the 911
system and so in FY 22 the division
answered 481 032 911 calls they
maintained a 51.64 second transfer time
for emergency medical dispatch they
achieved 99 quality assurance rate when
they were through their reviews of
5745 emergency medical dispatch calls
no significant changes to salary and
benefits in fy24 there is an increase in
overtime budgets in both 24 and 25 and
that's to ensure that we're manning the
they're staffed at both peace apps
appropriately and that no calls go
unanswered
322 000 of the increase in 25 are due to
increases in salary and benefits from
expected employee increments
and one million dollar increase in 24
and 25 are due to increases in operating
costs in general the majority of those
have to do with the licenses and this
and the contracts required for ensuring
the 911 system is up and running
including computer-aided dispatch and
automatic location identification
services
page 11 is the division of fire
standards and training and Emergency
Medical Services
the division's request for fy24 is 9.5
million dollars it's also 9.5 million
for fy25 and that's about a 13 increase
from FY 23
this division has 40 classified and one
unclassified position there are three
unfunded new classified positions that
are being requested the majority of this
division is instruction is provided by
part-timers and so that's one of the
well we'll talk about this in a moment
on the prioritized needs but shifting
away from the part-time model due to
challenges with with finding individuals
who are willing to teach those courses
and maybe seeing if there's an
opportunity for full-time instructors to
help meet the demand for firefighter one
and firefighter 2 trainings that are out
there
in FY 22 the division enrolled 20 140
students issued 1280 certifications
taught 897 courses they conducted 96 991
training hours licensed
5375 EMS providers and licensed 472
ambulances and five rotary Wing
Emergency Management I'm sorry emergency
response vehicles
the summary of significant changes for
24 and 25 217
000 of the increase in 24 and 182 000 of
the increase in 25 are due to increases
in salary and benefits including
part-time instructors to meet those fire
training needs
eight hundred and sixty thousand dollars
of the increase are due to increased
costs for instructional supplies as we
said prices have gone up there's also an
equipment replacement need for the new
candidate candidate physical ability
testing a trailer so the trailer needs
to be replaced that we currently have
and in prioritized needs we have here a
request for three new fire service
instructors and as I mentioned this
would be testing out a new model where
we'd be looking at full-time instructors
instead of part-timers especially when
delivering firefighter one and
firefighter two trainings those are the
trainings that are required firefighter
ones to be a full-time
firefighter server in New Hampshire
representative uh Bobby Richie Muller
thank you Mr chair quick question
um
if the fire if the full-time instructors
are replacing you know similar training
provided by part-timers I'm looking and
it seems that all the funded all the
funding is new wouldn't we have a
matching drop in the uh you know missing
wages for the part-timers that used to
deliver those classes we we absolutely
could so if if
if the committee were willing to fund
you know even I would say maybe two of
these positions if not all three we
could have a corresponding drop in our
our part-time money yes would you maybe
be able to provide us with those numbers
because frankly I would be comfortable
supporting the net increase but not the
gross increase and then hoping we'll
find the you know the cuts later so if
you could maybe update this number to
give us the net estimate of what may
cost after you account for those savings
yeah
thank you thank you for the question
representative
you had to ask what's that you had to
ask
um I just wanted to make sure it's still
the same it is yeah the source of the
fire funds are um it's actually driver
history records
and those are are purchased primarily
through insurance agencies but some
other
um some some other entities as well and
those funds support the fire fund which
supports fire standards and training and
EMS and also the division of fire safety
which is the Fire Marshal's Office
the challenges that we have with the
fire Fund in previous biennium have come
to head this biennium and so we're
required now to fully fund these areas
we need to increase fees in the fire
fund and you'll see in House Bill 2
there's some language changes to the one
fee that's in statute that would provide
the commissioner with authority to
make fee changes through rule making as
opposed through as opposed to statute to
allow us to be more flexible when when
prices increase
what kind of price is it for every
inquiry
I say it again I'm sorry a typical
inquiry here's a name here's the person
want their driver's records and
insurance yeah what would the bill be
um so it varies significantly
um it's different for you and I going in
and making a request versus a versus an
organization so the the organizations
would enter into a contract with us
there's typically an annual fee upwards
of ninety thousand dollars per year and
then they pay the per record fee on top
of that that depends upon if we're
giving them a flat file with X number of
Records or the actual record
um so it may be it may be several it may
be on the sense per record or a dollar
per record and maybe up to 15 per record
if if you're getting the full record
our our
budget only works if we increase all of
those fees this is not going to be any
one particular area everybody requesting
this data will have to pay
um an increased fee in order to fund
representative Murray can I just double
check you train 20 000 firefighters in
in a year is that the
20 000 students yeah yep that's right
hmm twenty thousand students trained a
year in the firefighting school that's
impressive yeah so not necessarily
firefighter one there's there's you know
there's other trainings we have the the
ARP with the the airplanes fuselage
that's there oh yeah yeah yep
yeah some of those are out of state
some of these students could be from out
of state some of these students could be
um from you know corporate
um there's different fee structure
depending upon if you're affiliated with
a fire department in New Hampshire and
if you're not and so those affiliated
with the Department of New Hampshire get
a discounted course rate those not have
to pay full price
and we also offer courses up north as
well
the Burton Training Academy facility in
Bethlehem
the the ray Burton training facility in
uh so then finally the division of fire
safety uh on page 12.
the request for the division of fire
safety which is the office of the fire
marshal is 4.9 million dollars and 24
and uh just under 5 million dollars in
fy25 it's a seven percent increase from
FY 23.
there are 23 classified and one
unclassified full-time position
authorized
within the division and there is one
unfunded full-time position that's new
that we're asking for
the highlights for fire safety and FY 22
they investigated 123 fire related
incidents conducted 323 Fire and Life
safety inspections
conducted
1139 building Plan reviews issued 777
modular housing labels and issued 856
permits for State University and
Community College building projects
significant changes for 24 and 25 151
000 of the increase in 24 and 235 000 of
the increase in 25 are due to increased
salary and benefit costs from scheduled
increments
124 000 of the increase in 24 and 25 is
required for replacement equipment
including replacement vehicles for fire
investigators similar to State Police
they have the same challenges across the
board we couldn't purchase vehicles for
a period of time
and then we talked a little bit about
the fire fund already and and the
challenges that we have there
the language in House Bill 2 will allow
us to move through rulemaking and make
those fee adjustments to support the
division of of fire safety here without
that funding
um
we would need to look at alter uh
ulterior funding options and potentially
moving to the division to the general
fund
um for the full budget amount but we're
confident that those fee increases will
will provide the revenue that's
necessary representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the questions since we haven't
received hb2 would you be kind enough to
expand a little on the changes that hb2
describes for your uh you know expanded
authorized used and revised fee setting
Authority because right now I got
nothing from there so anything you can
give me would be very useful in
understanding what we are looking at
sure absolutely
um if if I may just before we we move in
that because that's the next part of the
presentation right on the next page
um but we we've got the information
there
um there are two
new program Assistant two positions that
I wanted to talk about first
um
House Bill 2 also
which is all tied into house bill too
isn't it um House Bill 2 transfers The
Authority for inspecting Healthcare
facilities from HHS to the office of the
fire marshal
um it makes sense because we have
building inspectors and we have the
expertise to do that work HHS struggled
to hire people in those roles so we
coordinated with HHS coordinated our
budgets they reduced their general fund
spend by the amount that we needed to
create the positions and increase ours
it didn't make it into our budget and so
that's one of the prioritized needs that
we have listed that quite frankly I
debated maybe putting it on an Errata
list and saying oops there's a keying
error can we add this but because of the
dollar amount I wasn't comfortable doing
that so that's listed here that's one
that I would certainly ask the committee
for to support because it was simply it
got lost in the shuffle between the two
departments and that but budget impact
overall is is zero because we
coordinated our our increase with their
reduction
and then lastly the new program
Assistant two position in fire safety
this is a position specifically to
address 91a requests
um the division gets significant volume
for 91a requests and it they have to
meet them but it's a challenge because
they also have to respond to fires and
conduct their investigations timely
they're not able to to do everything and
so this position would be focused just
on meeting those 91a requests on a
so representative moving on the next two
pages are House Bill 2 summary items
um and um you know this is not the exact
language but it's uh for your
consideration uh it's worth us talking
about each one of these so
um the body worn and dashboard camera
fund uh this appropriates additional
Monies to the the body warm and
dashboard cam Camera Fun
this was established
um
previously I believe it was in House
Bill 2 uh established by House Bill 2
the last biennium and additional funds
were appropriated in the last
legislative session so 2 million had
been appropriated to date we've awarded
1.1 to 4.48 municipalities and we're on
a rolling basis as far as making these
funds available this would appropriate
another million dollars to that to that
fund
there's a new northern border Alliance
program which would include an
appropriation of 1.4 million dollars and
this would be to make grants available
to other state County local law
enforcement agencies and provide
division
um funding to State Police for
additional patrols along the northern
border to ensure that there's no illicit
activity that's happening in that area
this helps to supplement some of the
federal funding program that we've had
in the past but we've seen reductions in
those funds and so this addresses that
particular need
there's also
um
an adjustment to the statute that
authorizes the auxiliary State Police
right now that statute caps the number
of part-time Troopers that we can hire
at 16.
if this would eliminate that cap just
authorize us to hire auxiliary Troopers
the limiting factor will be our budget
so class 50 is our budget for part-time
funding we'll limit how many part-time
Troopers we can purchase we can purchase
we can hire
uh
the next two uh have to do with the fire
fund fees that we talked about
copies of certificates and Motor Vehicle
Record fees this would eliminate the
fees that are currently specifically
identified in statute and allow the
department to go through rulemaking to
set the fees instead
and then expansion of the uh
of the of the entities who are able to
utilize those fees
um
right now we're prohibited from
providing driver history records to a
federal entity
entirely this would allow us to do so
but only for the same usage purposes as
a as a corporate entity would be allowed
for so there's still restrictions on
that data not building databases and
things of that nature but they'd have
the same usage as an insurance company
and have have the ability to obtain that
information
the residential care and health facility
inspection this is related to those two
positions that we just spoke about
transferring that function from HHS over
to the Department of Safety
and then there is a new division of fire
safety position this is a program
Assistant two
um to manage building and fire code
amendment process
um this was another piece that was
missed in in Senate Bill 443 uh during
the 22 legislative session
we shared that we needed this position
to um to manage these amendments and
make sure that they're being processed
correctly for whatever reason it wasn't
added to the statute and we were told to
go through the budget process instead so
page
14. this is authorization allowing the
department to fill unfunded positions as
long as our expenditures don't exceed
the total appropriated amount
so if we do still have unfunded
positions at the end of this process
this allows us through vacancies to fund
those throughout the year if we're able
to
the substance abuse enforcement program
this is also known as Granite Shield
this uh this program is focused on
reducing narcotics inflows into the
state and this appropriates appropriates
408 000 in general funds to safety for
overtime for forensic laboratory and
State Police over time related to the
program and also 1.6 million in funds to
award to local and county law
enforcement agencies for overtime costs
focused on
um focused on these law enforcement
activities
emergency medical and Trauma services so
there's some statutory changes that are
made related to naloxone and also
defining peer support groups
to to
allow more individuals to administer
naloxone without fear of any sort of
ramification so similar to an AED device
if somebody's having a heart attack kind
of following that model so that's what
those do there
there's language here to just suspend
rsa99 this is the RSA that limits the
percentage of Highway and um
Casa collections funds to 26 percent of
the total revenue that's collected
um if you recall there's a fund balance
in the highway fund and part of that is
from General funds that were added in
the previous biennium and so that 26
percent will likely be
um
likely be over that 26 percent but it's
because there's a fund balance that
representative Heath thank you that
won't hurt any of our matching monies
no I don't believe so okay
um
thank you I just wanted to make sure it
should okay thank you representative
Weiler explain how what what figures
you're using to do the 26 percent
um so it's the
Revenue uh collected from it's it's
whatever was in in the statute which I'm
going from memory so
um well that was that was mine from
about 15 years ago okay so it's the re
the revenues that are collected
um and then it's the total Highway fund
uh Appropriations and cost of
collections Appropriations
and so it would be 25 26 in total and I
kind of defer to Mickey two on this as
well yeah I'll make sure that the budget
is either in compliance or a suspension
is included in House Bill 2 that law did
change maybe three budgets ago now to
include gross motor vehicle and road
tolls so one thing Steve may or may not
have included is
um if you recall a DOT came in the
betterment account is restricted and the
Senate Bill 367 that 4.2 Cent gas tax is
those are not part of unrestricted but
they are part of the Gross Road toll
collection and all of those dollars are
appropriated to dot so I think when you
factor in those programs and include
those as part of gross motor vehicle and
road toll collections will will probably
be compliant but we'll monitor that as
division two makes is thank you thank
you
the key here was we wanted to we were
aware of this and we wanted to make sure
that
um if we weren't compliant it was
addressed
state and local cyber security grant
program so
um
representative Petri this is the the
matching funds we talked about earlier
about uh to support the federal FEMA
money
um this is the state share of those
funds which will help to improve state
and local cyber security
and then finally the state police
cruiser appropriation 3.5 million for 52
Cruisers which will help us get to a
healthy Fleet and to a level that we can
maintain over the future biennium and
not run into the the backlog of
purchases that we're trying to work
through right now
representative Mueller thank you Mr
chair
I completely understand the need to get
the vehicles but then I'm trying to look
down six years or whatever down the road
and I don't want our you know vehicle
replacement program to look like a
python with a big you know egg in it you
know basically is there any way to
massage your Fleet replacement services
so we can flatten and you know make this
a bit more uh even over the long term I
understand it may be hard to do it at
once because you have 52 vehicles coming
in but I would just appreciate any
comments on how you plan to handle that
sure and I want to say we try to be as
conservative but yet accurate as
possible than anything we ask for I will
say this is um critical for the State
Police these 52 and then if we can
acquire those moving forward we go back
to our vehicle replacement plan which we
look at you know the miles I mean they
are when I when I say keeping vehicles
on the road that we have never you know
kept them to that extent in the past so
my question was strictly my question was
strictly about the replacement I'm not
concerned about your need I just you
know am trying to figure out if there is
a way to maybe play with their lives a
little so that we spread The
Replacements across a few budget Cycles
to not have a huge cost coming again in
whatever years when we need to replace
them all at once that's that's all there
is to it yeah that's
that's what these purchases in this in
the next biennium will allow us to do
um we are we are so far in the other
direction that this will this will right
size us and allow us to have steady
requests for replacement over the next
several biennium and the other thing is
as we fill these positions it becomes
more of an issue so when you have the
vacancies it's not as much but so it
representative Murray thank you can you
go back to the state and local cyber
security the grant program this enables
us to get federal funds is that right
um do we have those federal funds now
it's so isn't this
why would this not have been included in
the budget if it's important for us to
get this matching money from Federal
it's it's all it's all happened
quickly
um and outside of the budget process
within the last
six months um we so we just brought an
item to fiscal
um this last meeting and to GNC to
appropriate the federal award
um and so we didn't know that whether we
would get the award or not and
um that that's why it wasn't included in
the operating budget per se
so do I so I understand so this is
something presumably I could presume
that this would have been included in
the budget had you known about it in
time
if we had already received the federal
award the okay then we would have been
able to take a different a different
question on your substance abuse
of course we have neighbors at all have
legalize marijuana how much of a problem
is that you know in
I mean you know it when it's legal on
the other side I mean it's it's going to
come to our side of the border and uh
that would seem like uh it's it'd be a
hard enforcement uh I mean do you what's
it called I mean the cost of that is
well I just I mean
all law enforcement Falls the law they
adhere to it you know no matter what the
border states are doing but one of the
areas with with the marijuana that we've
been focusing on as I know uh the office
of Highway Safety is trying to prepare
for any increases and you know drivers
that could be impaired by marijuana so
we're looking at that we're being aware
of it you know on the on the street you
know when an officer comes in contact
with anyone I think they they're trained
they know how to deal with you know what
is what is a violation what's you know
what's a felony
um but I think the future that they're
wise they're focusing on our Dre program
and how do we address those that might
be impaired by um by drugs as opposed to
alcohol
um representative Murray can I follow up
on that in terms of costs and this may
be impossible to answer if marijuana
becomes legal
what would effect that have on you on
um criminal justice or you know what
police the state police can do
um is anyone arresting someone for
marijuana now since it's been
decriminalized what would be the
difference it becomes legal are you
doing spending money now because it's
not legal would you be spending money
more later on if it is legal can you
give some sort of a scenario or
narrative about what the changes would
be for law enforcement if it became
legal
that that that's a complex question and
I guess the the simple answer is we
would um we would follow the Law
whatever the you know the policy leaders
whatever the law was
um yeah so yeah alcohol is legal so you
get it arrested for over indulging so
even if cannabis is legal you're going
to get arrested for misuse but I'm right
now you're you could be arrested for a
use not just necessarily misuse so I'm
wondering the difference I think it's a
great question and it comes back to
training so whatever let's say you know
whatever laws were passed if it had to
do with weights or amounts or whether
it's possessing or transporting I mean
obviously if you're impaired you're
impaired no matter what the substance is
so I think
um I can't put a cost on it we always
look at the lab you know I can say that
our backlog in the lab has gone down
significantly since recent changes so
they've been able to focus on more
dangerous drugs like the Fentanyl and
heroin and cocaine but it will all come
down to training and that's really the
the job of you know of the Chiefs and
the police academy and the leaders so
um so I think the key is to just uh and
that's that's with anything in law
enforcement whatever changes are out of
the law so but again the the we're
focused on the on the highway safety
component of it now and and we have been
as we've been seeing you know what's
happened along the borders
representative Buco do you have a
question
yes I do thank you
um back where it says uh
in hospital 2
um the change in a change in the law to
allow Department of Safety to set the
fees
from to promote a record motor records
I guess my question is what what fees
so
yeah so those are the uh those are motor
vehicle driving driving history records
um and those are made available to
um certain uh
certain entities by law who have access
to those for a fee and so right now the
fee for those those records
um is set in statute specifically in the
the dollar amount I believe it I believe
it's 13 uh per record and 13 and 15
depending upon if it's the individual
record or the large group record and so
we would eliminate that fee from the
statute
but require the department to go to jail
car to establish the fee moving forward
which gives us the ability to make
adjustments as we need to when prices
increase
right okay thank you um one one
follow-up back back here somewhere said
that we had five rotary
rotary Wing aircraft
I believe that would be for dark correct
it's a Lifeline well we have we have
five of them no we don't we don't own
those well okay that was my question
thank you what the ambulances yeah thank
you yeah yeah representative uh Mueller
thank you Mr Richard just to continue
building a little on the whole impact of
possible legalization of marijuana
obviously it's a complex topic and Way
Beyond this afternoon but
while it may
require a bit more work in terms of road
safety assuming High utilization and
therefore higher abuse area
what would you say just at a very high
level for the entire department of
safety would you expect that to make you
know
to be more of a burden in terms of more
work or decrease your burden a little in
terms of just expenses and Staffing and
do you expect less or more work if that
happens overall at the state level and I
know it's not really a fair question
just curious if you have a you know
again I would just say this I think we
would all agree if we saw an increase in
crashes if we saw an increase in fatal
crashes loss of life if we saw an
increase in calls for service if you saw
that you would see you would see
increases but again I can't predict
um but um you know just just focusing on
um I think what's you know near dear to
everyone it's just being safe when
you're on the road and so that's really
where a lot of our conversations have
come around we just recently
had an item to expand to uh tests oral
fluid for to see on impairment like we
have the portable breath test to see if
somebody roadside has been consuming
alcohol I think they these machines text
test for six drug classes so you know
we're looking
um we're trying to stay current and so
that's that's really where a lot of the
so um if we could now move to you have
um the first is the multi-page document
and this is a list of this summarizes
the prioritized needs that we spoke
about in the presentation but it puts
them in priority order because again we
we presented at the division level you
had division priorities this is
Department level priorities so I just
want to take a moment to walk through
these quickly just to make sure that the
committee that if you have any questions
on any of these we're happy to address
them so the first are the two new
full-time program Specialists three
positions for the health care facility
inspection function that I mentioned was
really something that just got missed in
in the budget so
um we would we would hope that that was
something that we could add in at this
phase the next are four existing data
control clerk positions at the DMV and
these are the ones that process driving
history records and make sure those are
up to date the third priority is the
existing program specialist one an
existing program specialist two
positions in homeland security and those
are ensuring that the Homeland function
are occurring on a regular basis
well quick question about that formally
we very rarely saw any general funds for
Homeland Security and now we are
um
there's there's not there shouldn't be a
lot of General functions in your chart
it's not a lot yeah it's about 43
million uh 43 000 I think yep so um so
there's always been some general funds
in homeland security the directors uh
position itself has always been funded
with General funds um and there's always
been a small piece that's attached we've
tried to keep that as low as possible
but there's always been some so all of
these are we're looking for
authorization for these positions
using the dollars the federal dollars
so it may be a misunderstanding you
the funding for for these for the
existing positions what you're asking
for yes it's a mix um so it's Federal
private local in general so that's the
mix that's in the accounting unit yeah
so in this particular case even though
we're asking for 156
000 the general fund to ask is only 54
000. thank you yes sorry I understand
yep representative Murray thank you in
the same vein it looks like with
Homeland Security you're asking for two
additional positions
in the budget it looked to me like there
are four additional positions so
somewhere I'm missing two
so I haven't gone through this very
detailed but it struck out it stood out
at me this I'm on page 429 of the budget
yeah under the homeland security okay
and at the bottom they're
223 there are two positions in 24 there
and I'm sure I've just missed something
up here this is in um I think I think I
know what this is give me a second
before 29 I can't find the other numbers
fast enough yeah so go from two to six
so so those are that changes because of
four full-time temporary positions that
were converted into full-time
um permanent positions so they were they
were funded
um through additional Federal monies
outside of the budget process through
fiscal through GNC and we need those
positions and are making them permanent
so there are not new positions they're
redefined positions thank you yes
foreign
so page two of the prioritized needs
listing
um is the
three criminalist positions within the
lab
so again those are supporting the
forensic biology section and then also
toxicology
our fifth priority is the new program
specialist two position in the digital
evidence unit in State Police to support
the body and Cruiser camera program and
making sure that those requests are are
processed timely for Discovery requests
number six is a new position in Human
Resources the human resources
coordinator 2 to ensure that we're
processing all transactions timely that
number seven
is
the increase in credit card fees at the
DMV
and based on some of the reaction it
sounds like we should probably consider
the convenience fee option
um
number eight is fire standards and
training admin these are the new uh fire
safety instructors the full-timers as
opposed to the part-timers so we'll
we'll come back with the reduction in
part-time money to see if we can
um
absorb some of those by reducing
part-timers and give that option to the
committee number nine is the new program
assistant position in the Fire Marshal's
Office to address 91a requests
and then number 10 are the
um security enhancements at the DMVs
that's adding the glass and then also
the security monitors for the high
number 11 is adding a DMV station to
Plymouth which helps to improve customer
service at Concord and Tamworth and
address the demands in The Lakes Region
area
and then 12
which are split up into a b and c
because of the accounting units these
are the 17 previously unfunded Trooper
positions so funding these would allow
us to increase Patrol Services across
the state in addition to maintaining
so that's the prioritized list of our
prioritized needs
and then the one page item similar setup
these are a rata adjustments that we're
asking for
um this is these are adjustments that we
intended to include in the budget but
for whatever reason they were not so the
first is transferring positions between
um within the division of emergency
services and Communications between the
Bureau of communications and the
communications section itself this is
budget neutral it's shifting positions
to where they they should be paid out of
no impact on the funding the second is a
similar situation it's transferring
positions between two accounting units
in Motor Vehicles because of where
they're doing the work now it's all cost
of collection zero budget impact
the third is a revenue Source correction
of three thousand dollars in DMV there's
some general funds that are incorrectly
coded those should be agency income so
we'll reduce General funds by three
thousand seven dollars
and then the fourth is to appropriate
thirty seven thousand dollars in other
funds for
um 911 cyber security Consulting so this
was a key this was missed during keying
um it's 37 000 because of that it was
included in the Errata listing as
foreign
that really concludes the presentation
that we have for you today
representative Heath thank you Mr chair
um I would like to move that we accept
the
um
changes that you just gave us the
corrections
um as one of the activities that we need
to take care of Mickey am I okay doing
this yes that would be appreciated
because I can get off to that but get
that behind us now yeah
should I should be the one recording it
give me a moment please
well we can we can do that with a show
hand right this is just like Corrections
all right we can we can just do it with
a show of hands oh good any discussion
uh before we uh vote on that we are just
talking about the last there at the
adjustments nothing else got it
everybody understand the emotion
any discussion all in favor show hands
unanimous
excuse me
very good Don thank you very much for
being here today uh any other questions
for the uh
power safety
can I sure
this is a really good presentation
everything was very very clear and I
appreciate the amount of work you put
into this because this is probably one
of the more concise and comprehensive
presentations that we've seen
thank you
he brought his assistant
yeah that's right
yeah
so one of the bills that we've retained
is House Bill 560 relative to the uh
contact person notification program I
don't know if anyone wanted to ask the
department about that bill I know we had
questions when we had our brief work
session
that's the bill that um would create a
list for individuals who
um may not be competent to speak on
their own behalf right and so then if
they were pulled over State Police would
be able to it's a contact person
notification program for that situation
yes yeah the main question was if my you
know not actually but my Looney husband
goes off on his own and he's pulled
somewhere and he doesn't have any
information on him he's just this person
on the side of the road having me as his
emergency contact isn't helpful unless
you can attach me to him in some way so
how do if you know if this is this past
the question was how do you how does the
officer get the contact information for
the person who is without
you know identification and maybe you
know without some reason at that point
do you see what I'm saying you can have
a big list of emergency contacts but if
you can't attach those contacts to an
unidentified person what good does it do
yeah so it would have to be tied into
one of the one of one of the searches
that the Troopers utilize when they're
um pulling someone when they look
someone up so it seems to me it's tied
into the DMV system more than anything
would there what would there be that
they're searching for I mean would they
fingerprint him if he has nothing on him
what what can the trooper do
yeah see I I don't I don't have any
specifics on it um I know that State
Police has been involved in the bill and
has been kind of following it and and uh
but I I don't know enough about the
details to really be able to answer that
representative we created a card some
time ago
for hearing impaired or so on that they
would show it to the officer
to say that I'm hearing impaired or so
some other problem and if they've always
had that with them
then you could put that on that same
card the contact person is
but if there's anybody that I will as
problem communicating or use American
sign language as something that the
officer is not going to know right that
they'd have to okay call this person on
the phone and you know
representative Heath thank you I think
with the grown number of children that
we have with autism and the varying
range of disabilities that we're seeing
I think I don't know for a fact but for
me it seems like it would be wonderful
years ago I had a young man that had
dysarthria or couldn't talk was stopped
they thought he was drunk
um arrested it was very difficult for
him if he had had a card he would have
just been able to show it to the police
officer so I think that's the purpose of
this bill if I'm I'm not sure I guess
maybe that's what I'm asking
um
we have to figure that out uh
representative I'll be reaching more
since I have the laptop I pulled up the
bill really quickly because honestly I
didn't remember the bill by the number I
my brain doesn't work that way but
essentially this says that somebody
would provide law enforcement you know
information about this is the right
person to talk to me whether it's
through a guardian or directly or
whatnot and when that person is stopped
there should be a way for them to be
told hey don't try to talk to this
person after they identify them you
really need to try to engage with this
contact person because the person you
are spoken with cannot handle
communication properly so that's you
know is you know what the bill is trying
to do and since you're here we're just
trying to figure out what are your
thoughts on how much this could be
implemented how would it work
Ed sure if I could just add um two cents
about this so I think the real issue is
the legal competence of communicating
with someone when you realize they're
not fully up
to the task when they interact with law
enforcement I think the intent of the
bill is to provide a resource for folks
once they identify that you know okay
that maybe this isn't totally the right
conversation it should be having right
now they can reach out to this list if
they're able to identify I think you
know trying to connect the dots of like
who is this person
are they competent to handle this
discussion if we've decided they're not
then the resources provided that they
can go to a list and try to figure out
who is the correct contact I don't think
it's going to be doing the front end of
that connection connecting the dots but
it's the back end resource if I'm
understanding it correctly so that the
you know law enforcement has a resource
at their fingertips once they're aware
of the situation I don't again I don't
think that it's really probably it
sounds like a self-reporting issue too
so families are aware of and you know
Guardians are aware if whether or not
they can take advantage of this of this
resource you know be added to the list
so
um I think what we're trying to connect
in our minds of how would this all work
is probably a step farther than the bill
actually intends to go I think it's
probably the back end of that
um you know legal response to to having
these interactions so
maybe um
expanding on that maybe if we put it on
because we figure if they're driving all
right you could put because you you do a
check you know
you could check their driver's license
right the driver's license in the plate
the vehicle registration would which
would not contain any of this right but
you could we could put it on there well
I think that would I think that would
you know you would have to have further
discussions that the only thing I'd like
to to I don't I can't speak
um
um to the bill but I just would share
that there are a lot of um systems in
place now when we have missing of
vulnerable folks you'll see as you you
know see the news whether it's a silver
alert or
um you know and I think a lot of these
issues
um even like at 9-1-1 you know in my
recent meeting with director Doyle
there's systems in place so that you
know family members can provide
information in advance of some unique
circumstances at the household before
the respondents get there you know maybe
some of these conversations take place
at the local level you know and but if
somebody is is missing or you know is
vulnerable
um just having a place where you can
report that and a lot of times with all
of these they put you know who do we
call who so I I think it's I think it's
it it's an important conversation but
um to just say whether it would go on a
driver's license or this you know would
take a lot more discussion
representative Heath thank you
um Mr chair so but if we have if this
bill passed it must have passed to get
to us I'm assuming we have it so is
there a cost will there be a cost has
been a fiscal note
so the bill did pass and was referred
here for review and there is a 50 000
appropriation only in fiscal 24 for that
bill uh so that could be something if
this committee the committee has voted
to retain that and consider it with
House Bill too to update the department
I should have had you more prepared on
this one I'm sorry about that and we are
happy to go back to get the information
you want to really look at it and um and
study this and be able to speak uh
intelligently that would be great thank
you
okay very good thank you
anybody else
thank you very much thank you appreciate
you being here
thanks